bonjour merci beaucoup de votre présence
merci d'être aussi nombreux donc je suis
Michael Vallet je suis le président de
la commission d'enquête qui a été initié
à la demande de mon collègue président
de groupe Claude malré et qui rapporteur
de la commission et à qui je vais tout
de suite passer la parole pour qu'il
puisse vous exposer un peu le résultat
de nos travaux et après quoi c'est le
principe ne sont évidemment à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
voudrais me joindre à vous remerciements
et souhaitez les bienvenus à vous tous
qui avait répondu à notre invitation je
voudrais remercier d'abord le président
lui-même pour sa présidence pendant ces
quatre mois de commission d'enquête à la
fois efficace et bienveillante je
voudrais remercier nos collègues
sénateurs qui dont plusieurs d'entre eux
ont été particulièrement assidus dans
une au sein d'une commission qui a connu
pas mal d'auditions même et de
déplacement
et je voudrais avoir une mention
particulière pour les administrateurs
sous l'égide de Marc marcellier qui nous
ont accompagnés je pense que la plupart
d'entre vous connaissent le
fonctionnement des commissions d'enquête
parlementaires et savent que le rôle des
administrateurs est essentiel pour
parler comme Renault Muselier en général
moi j'ai l'habitude de dire que les
administrateurs font tout et que nous on
fait le reste en tout cas merci beaucoup
du travail qui a été effectué comme je
le disais à l'instant
cette commission a duré quatre mois elle
elle a pas mal travaillé plusieurs
dizaines d'auditions des déplacements
notamment auprès de la Commission
européenne à Bruxelles des
questionnaires aux organismes de
régulation et à TikTok et la
consultation de nombreux rapports
souvent internationaux et de nombreuses
enquêtes journalistiques
la le titre de la commission d'enquête
était commission d'enquête sur
l'utilisation du réseau social Tik Tok
son exploitation des données sa
stratégie d'influence et le titre du
rapport qui n'est pas exactement le même
que celui de la commission d'enquête
mais qui précise un petit peu ce que
nous voulons dire c'est je ne sais pas
si on voulait oui je vois qu'on vous la
distribuer la tactique TikTok opacité
addiction et
ombre chinoise
avant de commencer je voudrais faire une
réflexion préliminaire je crois qu'il y
a une chose qui nous a frappé et qui a
frappé tous les commissaires
c'est un c'est un oxymore
que j'appellerai une transparence opaque
on a vraiment tous été frappé au fur et
à mesure de l'avancée de la commission
par le fait que
Tik Tok annonce partout y compris sur
dans l'ensemble des pays pas seulement
en France mais sur ces sites sur ces
sites internet sur sa politique de
confidentialité dans les auditions que
nous avons eu dans les courriers le mot
de transparence revient toujours si vous
allez sur le site politique du
confidentialité vous verrez ces mots
transparents ouverture etc etc on a
l'impression que c'est un des un délai
atmotiv un des slogans choisis par cette
plateforme pour se décrire et
parallèlement ou plutôt
perpendiculairement
tous ceux que nous-mêmes dans les
auditions mais surtout tous ceux
régulateurs
organismes d'état commissaire européen
chaque fois que nous avons une émission
ou quasiment chaque fois 90% du temps le
premier la première réponse que nous
avons eu c'est opacité
opacité pour tout le monde et donc on a
eu on a cette impression à la suite de
cette commission d'enquête à la fin de
cette commission d'enquête qu'il y a
vraiment une opposition entre les
protestations de transparence de la part
de Tik Tok et de ses responsable et une
réalité qui est celle d'une opacité et
d'une opacité qui est
[Musique]
manifestement
voulu alors le premier le premier
exemple
et bien entendu celui par lequel je vais
commencer le premier exemple c'est celui
qui nous pose un problème majeur bien
entendu de sécurité nationale que ce
soit maintenant ou dans le futur ce sont
les relations de Tik Tok avec la Chine
et bien entendu ce qui veut dire avec le
Parti communiste chinois
la Chine a une stratégie avérée de
guerre cognitif c'est comme ça qu'elle
l'appelle qui peut recourir à la fois de
l'influence via les plateformes
numériques qu'elles soient chinoises ou
d'autres pays bien entendu et la
collecte massive de données
les moyens de cette stratégie sont
connues puisqu'ils ne concerne pas que
Tik Tok il concerne toutes les sociétés
chinoises d'une certaine importance
contrôle de ces sociétés contrôle de
leur dirigeants installations de
cellules du Parti communiste chinois
participation au capital par le biais de
Golden share ou avec 1% du capital en
définitive le gouvernement chinois
contrôle à le contrôle sur l'ensemble de
la société et en plus une loi au fur et
à mesure de la présidence de Ji inping
vous le savez mieux que moi
les plusieurs lois ont été édictés pour
renforcer le contrôle sur les sociétés
pour forcer pour obliger ce qui était
d'ailleurs le cas déjà dans les faits
mais qui n'étaient pas encore dans la
loi pour obliger les sociétés à coopérer
avec les services de renseignement
chinois récemment s'y est et là on bien
entendu on est en plein dans notre sujet
s'il est ajouté une nouvelle loi sur et
d'autres sont en préparation sur
l'extra-territorialité pour le moment ça
n'était
rendu légal que sur le seul territoire
chinois aujourd'hui c'est ces
dispositions sont l'objet d'une
extraterrestériorité c'est à dire qu'il
s'applique au Chinois vivant ou
dirigeant des sociétés hors de Chine
alors sur l'extraterritorité ça n'est
pas propre au régime chinois puisque les
Américains ont aussi la même
extra-territorialité le problème c'est
que c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
la collaboration avec les services de
renseignement et le Parti communiste
chinois n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que la collaboration avec les
services d'une démocratie mais ça n'est
pas particulier à la Chine
donc à ce titre c'est le cas pour c'est
le cas pour TikTok c'est le cas pour
toutes les grandes sociétés comme
Tencent comme wechat etc et donc il n'y
a pas d'exception
à ce titre donc Tik Tok évidemment joue
un rôle particulier puisque avec plus
d'un milliard d'utilisateurs et dont 22
millions aujourd'hui en France les
autorités chinoises ne peuvent pas se
désintéresser ce serait comme on nous
l'a dit une faute professionnelle des
services chinois que de ne pas le faire
les relations avec la Chine tout ce que
je dis est bien entendu dans le rapport
by dance la maison mère et TikTok sont
dépendants de la Chine et de l'État
chinois sur tous les plans sur le plan
technique sur le plan capitalistique sur
le plan juridique et sur le plan
politique
les dirigeants du dicloc passe leur
temps à dire le contraire
baiden c'est une société internationale
parfois même américaine distille et
deuxième antiktok est séparé de la Chine
il n'y a pas de TikTok en Chine
l'application correspondante s'appelle
douille et elle n'a rien à voir
tous toutes ces déclarations sont
fausses et il est assez facile d'autres
que nous l'ont montré je pense qu'on a
ajouté un certain nombre de de preuves
et d'arguments qui montrent que c'est
ces déclarations sont faciles à démentir
je disais 4 plans la première le premier
plan est le plan capitalistique
une bonne partie du capital de by dance
limited caïmans puisque
nous parlons d'opacité la première
opacité est bien entendu c'est dès qu'on
a créé une société Biden c'est TikTok
hors de Chine on ne l'a pas installé
dans dans des circonstances je dirais
habituelle on l'a installé dans aux îles
Caïmans qui est classé par je me
rappelle plus le nom de l'organisme qui
qui planche sur sur les paradis fiscaux
comme le deuxième paradis fiscal dans
l'importance des secrets et de l'opacité
le deuxième derrière les îles vierges au
monde
où évidemment l'anonymat
[Musique]
l'impossibilité de rentrer dans le
détail de la société et majeur
de ce point de vue là pour reprenez la
transparence en s'installant aux îles
Caïmans je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
une tactique qui soit de
qui soit très crédible donc
une bonne partie
le baidens aux îles Caïmans et ce qu'on
appelle une vie une vague interest
entity c'est une façon assez fréquente
pour un certain nombre de sociétés
chinoises qui veulent se développer à
l'étranger de le faire tout en tout en
gardant d'une part l'opacité et d'autre
part le contrôle
le capital il est donc bien entendu
extrêmement difficile pour ne pas dire
impossible d'accéder aux détails de des
associés et des actionnaires de Biden
Skyman néanmoins on peut en avoir
aujourd'hui une approximation
extrêmement forte puisque d'une part
bindens annonce elle-même un certain
tous les fonds de pension tous les
actionnaires internationaux qui
participent et qui sont là unique bien
entendu pour faire de l'argent pour
faire du profit et qui sont la plupart
du temps des fonds américains ou
d'autres ou européens qui possèdent sans
doute à peu près 60% mon sentiment et
que c'est plutôt moins de 60% et
peut-être même de 50 % mais ils
annoncent
60%, tout en se gardant bien
d'annoncer quels sont les autres
actionnaires les autres actionnaires ils
sont essentiellement deux monsieur Jacky
mind donc un chinois qui a créé by dance
il y a quelques années en Chine
et d'autre part Lyon robot qui est
l'actuel le PDG de bydens qui lui aussi
d'origine de Chine continentale et qui a
EU2 possède selon certaines sources 20%
à mon avis beaucoup plus de 20% du
capital et 20 autres% étant destiné aux
salariés sans qu'on sache ce que veulent
dire le mot salarié et quelles sont ses
salariés de toute façon ceci a assez peu
d'importance puisque comme dans d'autres
pays d'autres sociétés chinoises les
[Musique]
le problème de le principe de la Golden
share existe et que par conséquent les
droits de vote au sein de ce de cette
entreprise ne correspondent pas au
montant du capital apporté et que les
droits de vote et je n'en ai bien
entendu pas la preuve et pas la
certitude mais il est absolument
probable que ces droits de vote sont
concentrés dans les mains de Monsieur
Jack gaming de Monsieur Lyon Goubeau
et que
par conséquent je vais en dire un mot
dans un instant par leur intermédiaire
sont sur le contrôle de l'État chinois
il faut y ajouter que parmi les
actionnaires qui ne sont pas
directement des fondateurs qui font
partie des fonds de pension et des
investisseurs internationaux se trouvent
un fond
[Musique]
chinois qui est dirigé par Monsieur
nilschen se font chinois il s'appelle
Sequoia China donc il fait partie des
60% c'est pour ça que je dis il est
probable que le contrôle de l'État
chinois s'exerce sur non pas sur 40 %
mais probablement sur au moins 50 %
puisque parmi les investisseurs
internationaux se trouvent le français
koïa China dirigé par Monsieur Nilsen
qui siège au conseil d'administration de
baid dance
en sa qualité donc de représentants du
fond séquoia monsieur Nilsen dans sa
biographie a été membre du 13e Comité
national de la Conférence consultative
politique du peuple chinois un forum qui
mêle des officiels du parti et des
membres des élites il est l'exemple même
de membres du Parti communiste chinois
qui font la transition avec les la
société civile il est également
vice-président du comité des fonds de
capitalistes de l'association de gestion
d'actifs de Chine et directeur du forum
d'entrepreneur YAB uliciana qui relève
de la Fédération chinoise de l'Industrie
et du Commerce
voilà en ce qui concerne la structure
capitalistique de l'entreprise il faut
ajouter
que
lorsqu'on parle du contrôle chinois je
salue Catherine Morin de saillie qui
nous rejoint
[Musique]
qui est l'un des fondateurs le principal
fondateur avec Leandro de baiden s'il y
a quelques années
[Musique]
a subi un certain nombre de
comment dire de mise au point pour
parler pour utiliser une litote de la
part du gouvernement chinois et
notamment lorsqu'il dirigeait au sein de
by dance une série de
filiales
celle qui s'appelle notamment tout Yao
où il s'est fait rappeler à l'ordre
parce qu'il avait eu la mauvaise idée de
faire quelques quelques réflexions
satiriques sur le gouvernement chinois
qu'il l'a obligé à faire une
autocritique c'est intéressant de lire
un certain nombre de passages de cette
auto critique parce que ça montre bien
comment se comment se passent les choses
vous avez bien entendu vous connaissez
comment l'histoire de Jackman histoire
du président de pindou etc etc qui se
défacto ont été obligés de céder leur
part de ce de se et d'ailleurs pour
certains de disparaître purement et
simplement ou en tout cas de s'effacer
de la vie publique tout simplement
j'enghini n'a eu la chance de pouvoir
rester président
actionnaire de by dance international
mais au prix d'une autocritique assez
violente qui date de 2018 et que je dont
je vous lis un extrait depuis que j'ai
reçu hier la note des autorités de
régulation je suis plein de remords et
de culpabilité qui m'ont empêché de
dormir
nous n'avons pas été attentifs en tant
que start-up en développement rapide
dans le sillage du 18e congrès national
du Parti communiste chinois nous sommes
pleinement conscients que ce
développement a été permis par cet air
glorieuse j'exprime ma gratitude pour
cette occasion historique de réformes
économique et d'ouverture et ma
gratitude envers ce gouvernement qui a
permis de développement de l'industrie
technologique le privilège que j'ai de
l'âge dans cette dans cette salle et
André gethelin sourit me fait penser au
texte de la Révolution culturelle à une
époque différente de celle d'aujourd'hui
mais je termine par le plus intéressant
je continue l'autocritique de Djang
gaming il faut approfondir la
coopération avec les médias officiels
augmenter la diffusion des contenus
officiels et s'assurer que la voix des
médias officiels soit relayée avec force
renforcer le système de responsabilité
de la rédaction en chef corrigé
entièrement les déficiences dans le
contrôle des algorithmes et des
ordinateurs renforcer les opérations et
les contrôles humain
[Musique]
séparation et notamment sur le plan
technique c'est presque une caricature
c'est à Pékin ou à shanga je ne sais pas
mais c'est en Chine que sont réalisés
les principaux les principaux les
principaux opérations techniques sans
lesquels Tik Tok ne peut pas fonctionner
tous les brevets tous les brevets des
milliers de brevets sont déposés par
binding Biden technologies c'est à dire
que les TikTok aucun Tik Tok
international a part quelques petits
brevets pour s'adapter au marché locaux
tous les brevets les milliers de brevets
appartiennent à la société
international
l'algorithme et les principaux
ingénieurs qui le gèrent qui l'améliore
puisqu'il y a besoin d'une gestion au
quotidien et notamment de l'utilisation
de données au quotidien tous ces toutes
ces personnes qui travaillent sur
l'algorithme principal sont en Chine et
sont des ingénieurs chinois je précise
au passage que j'ai rien contre les
Chinois parce que lorsqu'on a fait ces
auditions madame masure m'a dit mais
pourquoi vous nous reprochez de
l'utiliser des ingénieurs chinoises et
du racisme elle a pas utilisé le moral
ainsi mais c'était proche il a fallu que
je lui explique évidemment on n'était
pas là pour dire que les Chinois étaient
un péril jaune mais que c'était le
problème de leur inféodulation
obligatoire au régime chinois et et de
leur obligation de livrer les données si
on leur demandait donc
tout est
l'essentiel de la technique de
l'application TikTok et réguler depuis
la Chine vous le savez sans doute
puisque c'est un Bossuit je conseille
newsware de je crois que c'est de suite
qu'il a révélé il y a quelques mois en
novembre 2022 les 80 mails qui ont été
piratés les 80 mails internes qui ont
été piratés montrent que
selon
une explosion qui a été utilisée dans un
de ses mails tout est vu à Pékin
par des ingénieurs chinois
les risques qui en découlent sont bien
nettoyer évident risque d'espionnage
risque de chantage risque de
désinformation au profit du régime
chinois
cette dépendance
explique cette dépendance structurelle
explique les nombreuses scandales qui
ont déjà émaillé la courte vie de Tik
Tok accès à des données et tout cela a
été prouvé bien entendu et fait l'objet
de d'articles et de rapport
qui existe déjà accès à des données
d'utilisateur depuis la Chine espionnage
de journalistes par des équipes
chinoises échangent de données
d'utilisateurs sur des groupes dans la
messagerie l'arc où il faut préciser que
l'ensemble des sociétés Tik Tok et
Douilly l'ensemble du groupe qui soit
chinois ou qu'il soit
international
internationaux communiquent à travers
une messagerie particulière que
communique pas à travers un certain
nombre de messageries commerciales que
qui sont utilisables qui sont achetables
et qui sont généralement les messageries
utilisées par la plupart des entreprises
ils communiquent avec une messagerie
Larque une messagerie maison qui
d'ailleurs est vendable aussi mais qui
est qui est une technologie développée
par Biden
cette messagerie s'appelle l'arc l a RK
et
de ce point de vue là c'est un autre non
seulement indice mais une autre
démonstration que l'ensemble du
personnel de Tik Tok qu'ils soient
chinois ou qu'il soit à l'étranger
communiquent sur la même messagerie et
partage évidemment
les mêmes messages
cette
troisième dépendance sur le plan
technique justifie les mesures prises
par de nombreux pays puisque les
services de renseignement de nombreux
pays ont attiré l'attention de leurs
autorités sur ce sujet sur la
possibilité d'exploitation des données
et par conséquent
un certain nombre de pays où vous le
savez ont interdit tout simplement il
s'agit de l'Inde de l'Indonésie d'autres
pays ont interdit l'application dans
leur pays d'autres et ça a été l'objet
de pas mal de nouvelles dans les mois
qui viennent de se passer ont interdit
pour leur fonctionnaires pour les
fonctionnaires d'État pour un certain
nombre d'autres fonctionnaires et la
Commission européenne
l'a fait il y a quelques semaines
sur le plan juridique
Tik Tok France est une société qui est
détenue à 100% par Tic-Toc UK qui
elle-même est détenue à 100% par TikTok
international qui est le même est
détenue dans une mesure que je ne
connais pas par by dance international
les deux donc situés aux îles Caïmans il
y a une
comment dire
jusqu'à une date récente et c'est une
chose qui m'a étonnée lorsque des
centaines d'articles et dans le monde
des milliers d'articles quand il est
consacré à Tik Tok mais en ce qui
concerne Tik Tok France tous les
articles que nous avons lu jusque-là
parler des deux dirigeants un dirigeant
des affaires publiques qui s'appelle
eric Garandeau sur lequel que vous
connaissez dans certains d'entre vous
ont parlé dans leurs articles et d'une
directrice opérationnelle qui s'appelait
qui s'appelle toujours Marlène masure
ce que personne n'avait relevé parce que
il n'y a eu elle ne figure pas dans
l'organigramme qu'il y a eu aucune
publicité à ce sujet et lorsque les
dirigeants TikTok sont interrogés bien
entendu ils ne la cite pas mais ce qui
ce que nous avons découvert au cœur de
cette enquête c'est que la présidente de
Tik Tok France s'appelle madame Zao Tian
que c'est une personne née en Chine
qui a fait ses études à l'Académie
diplomatique de Pékin qui forment des
diplomates mais qui ne forment pas comme
vous pouvez vous en douter que des
diplomates qui
[Musique]
a été pendant longtemps dans l'équipe
dirigeante de Sina c'est l'entreprise
qui possède waibo des principaux
portails chinois avec évidemment comme
les autres la cellule du Parti
communiste chinois la nécessité de
collaboration avec les autorités
chinoises etc et qui a été la dirigeante
de tout Yao au moment où Monsieur Jammie
était le président de Douillet donc il
contrôlait également tout Yao et qui a
fait cette autocritique et tout Yao
était fermé d'ailleurs pendant quelques
semaines
[Musique]
à ce moment-là je pense que la leçon a
été retenue par Tzang gaming et par
Madame John Ciao
lorsque nous avons interrogé monsieur
Garandeau sur sur cette
anomalie que nous l'avons demandé
pourquoi il nous avait pas cité dans
l'organigramme le nom de la présidente
elle-même il nous a expliqué qu'il
n'avait jamais rencontré
que cette dame n'avait aucune
responsabilité opérationnelle je précise
au passage qu'elle est aussi président
de Tik Tok UK et sans doute qu'elle a
d'autres fonctions dans le groupe by
dance
qui n'avait aucune responsabilité
opérationnelle il s'en est suivi pour
ceux qui ont regardé la vidéo de cette
audition un petit épisode assez
probablement amusant c'est que au fur et
à mesure que de l'addition c'est parce
que Monsieur Garandeau parlait de
l'absence de responsabilité
opérationnelle de Madame xantiao et moi
je parlais de des responsabilités
juridiques et on a eu une sorte de
quipro quiproquo évidemment voulu
où je lui ai expliqué que moi ce qui
m'intér c'était qu'à partir du moment où
Madame santiao à la responsabilité
juridique de Tik Tok France comme de tik
Toky c'est d'abord elle qui l'a déposé
au greffes du tribunal de commerce elle
n'a jamais mis les pieds en France mais
c'est sa signature qui est sur les sur
les papiers du tribunal de commerce et
que demain si Tic-Toc France doit être
fermé vendu fusionné ou quoi que ce soit
c'est pas monsieur Garandeau ou madame
masure à qui on demandera leur avis
c'est madame zanzao qui sera évidemment
le bras armé des dirigeants plus hauts
placés mais dirigeants qui sont ceux
avec lesquels elle travaille depuis
longtemps alors peut-être un petit une
petite précision qui va vous amuser
comme nous avions
montrer que nous étions assez préoccupés
à Monsieur Garandeau lors de cette
audition quelques jours plus tard
c'était il y a une semaine à peu près
monsieur Garandeau nous a envoyé un mail
en nous disant j'ai bien compris que la
présence de Madame xantiao comme
présidente de Tik Tok France
vous posez un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes et par conséquent je vous
annonce que Madame Santiago va être
remplacé à la tête nautique toc France à
la présidence de tikkok France par un
président ou une présidente d'origine
européenne voilà c'est l'avantage chez
qui sont c'est des gens pratiques et
mais c'est en même temps je suis pas sûr
que ce soit quelque chose de très de
très habile parce que c'est une sorte
c'est une sorte d'aveu
voilà donc en ce qui concerne les liens
avec la ligne j'ajoute juste
une petite chose c'est que tous les
dirigeants d'origine chinoise ou
d'origine singapourienne ce qui n'est
pas la même chose par exemple je vous
dissout qui est président de Tik Tok
international et d'origine
singapourienne donc il n'a pas les
obligations vis-à-vis du régime chinois
qu'on les autres mais tous ces
dirigeants dans gimines Lyon Roubaud
madame John ciao ont refusé
deux témoigner devant la commission bien
entendu nous voulions pas les efforcer
mais nous leur avons proposé de le faire
par évidemment on n'allait pas leur
demander de venir à Paris spécialement
pour nous voir mais on pouvait très bien
le faire par visio nous n'avons jamais
eu aucune et nous l'avons demandé à
Monsieur Garandeau nous l'avons demandé
deux fois ou trois fois qui nous a dit
oui oui je vous apporterai une réponse
nous n'avons jamais eu de réponse c'est
bien entendu un peu regrette
alors j'en ai fini avec les liens de de
nature capitalistique technique
juridique et politique avec la Chine
aujourd'hui
bien entendu ils ne font pour nous
absolument aucun doute et évidemment
c'est problématique au-delà des liens
avec la Chine
se pose le problème de l'opacité de Tik
Tok pas seulement dans le domaine
politique ou des liens avec le régime
chinois mais dans tous les domaines
selon l'arcom et vous le verrez dans le
rapport selon l'arcome Tik Tok et le
plus mauvais élève de toutes les
plateformes en matière de
confidentialité en matière d'opacité
alors que Tik Tok existe en France
depuis 5 ans dans le dernier rapport de
l'arcome qui date de décembre 2022 donc
qui est très récent c'est assez frappant
je crois qu'on a mis le tableau dans le
rapport c'est assez frappant vous avez
un rapport des tableaux puisque on pose
des questions aux plateformes avec
tel sujet telle réponse etc le tableau
est assez frappant puisqu'il comporte au
moins 50 lignes sur les 50 lignes vous
avez 49 ou peut-être même 50 n'a pas
répondu n'a pas répondu n'a pas répondu
c'est à dire que 5 ans après son
existence en France Tik Tok ne répondent
toujours
rien aucun mot à l'ensemble des demandes
de leur com et alors comme le dit tout à
fait alors comme est d'ailleurs très en
colère mais pour le moment ça ne semble
pas avoir de de conséquences et par
conséquent Tik Tok se permet de répondre
au régulateurs français je ne réponds
pas à vos questions c'est un blanc c'est
un exemple parmi d'autres
les sites spécialisés dans ce domaine
estime également que d'icloc est un très
mauvais élève newsguard a relevé sur
TikTok un nombre particulièrement élevé
de fausses informations
une modération surtout algorithmique et
très très difficile en personnel par
rapport à l'ensemble des autres
plateformes et seulement 1% des contenus
retirés le son pour désinformations
ça ne reflète bien entendu pas la
réalité le Shadow banning c'est à dire
la baisse le fait de conférer à des
messages de
d'utilisateur une baisse de d'écoute une
baisse une baisse d'audience sans lui
expliquer pourquoi et sans expliquer à
personne d'ailleurs pourquoi continue à
exister et surtout il reste lui
totalement opaque nous avons demandé au
dirigeants Tik Tok des explications sur
ce Shadow banning nous ne les avons pas
obtenu de la même façon que nous n'avons
pas obtenu de réponse sur le eating qui
est le contraire du Shadow banning
comment donner plus d'audience à telle
ou tel utilisateur ça n'est connu de
personnes ni des autres utilisateurs qui
croient lorsqu'ils font une vidéo qu'ils
sont à égalité de compétition avec
l'ensemble des utilisateurs de Tik Tok
ils ne le sont pas puisque TikTok choisi
lui-même ou elle-même je sais pas
comment on dit par le eating par les
pousseurs là c'est pas un problème
d'algorithme c'est ce sont des pousseurs
physiques qui décident et souvent sans
doute ce qui est d'ailleurs pas
critiquable en soi pour des raisons de
contractuelles pour des raisons
financières de pousser telle ou tel ou
telle influenceur plutôt que teloter
l'autre c'est des pratiques commerciales
mais qui sont pas en elle-même
répréhensible mais qui par le repacité
évidemment dans l'opposité pose un
problème particulier
il nous a semblé que Tik Tok a beaucoup
plus investi dans le lobbying et la
publicité en France et ailleurs que dans
la lutte contre la désinformation
est également un mauvais élève au regard
du rgpd alors ça c'est pas n'importe qui
qui nous l'a dit c'est le Ministre du
numérique Jean-Noël Barrault qui nous
dit dans une
dans une dans une audition
que TikTok ne respecte pas le rgpd
l'acnil nous a dit la même chose et nous
a dit qu'elle était en attente
puisqu'elle avait signalé puisque
maintenant les règles ont changé au sein
de la Commission européenne ils vont
d'ailleurs changer avec le DSA ça n'est
plus les régulateurs
des de chaque pays par exemple en France
LARCOM et la CNIL qui auront à juger des
qui ont à juger ou qui ont à juger des
dérapages mais comme le siège principal
le siège la maison mère de Tik Tok est
en Irlande c'est donc la BBC irlandaise
qui qui traite le sujet
nous sommes en attente nous didacthiles
d'une décision de la dip ici irlandaise
mais la CNIL a signalé et le sanction
devrait être assez prochaine annoncé à
ces prochainements
un certain nombre de violations du rgpd
la CNIL a commencé à l'instruire et
lorsque
le règlement s'est appliqué elle a dû la
transférer à la division qui est
regrettable parce qu'évidemment ça fait
deux ans que la CNIL a transmis et nous
n'avons toujours aucun retour de la DBC
l'acné l'estime que les données
prélevées sont très nombreuses ne
respectent pas la minimisation
c'est-à-dire s'organiser pour ne pas
trop donner de
[Musique]
pour ne pas trop utile pas pour utiliser
le minimum le minimum des données
nécessaires et non pas d'utiliser les
données superflues en fait ces données
non seulement sont extrêmement
nombreuses par rapport aux autres
plateformes les permissions demandées
sur les appareils sont extrêmement
nombreuses par rapport aux autres formes
mais en plus elle circule elle circule
énormément beaucoup plus que pour les
autres plateformes elle circule entre
les États-Unis entre l'Europe bien sûr
mais aussi les États-Unis la Malaisie
Singapour et la Chine en Chine on ne
sait pas exactement où puisque nous
n'avons eu aucune réponse à nos
questions avec un discours assez
incohérent en substance on nous dit à la
fois TikTok n'a pas du tout qui est
totalement autonome par rapport à la
Chine c'est que tu es incapable besoin
de la Chine alors qu'on sait que ça
n'est pas vrai et en même temps on nous
dit là je cite des sites Marlène masure
je crois nous envoyons des données en
Chine mais nous ne sommes pas en mesure
de vous dire ni à qui ni ou
deuxième
incohérence par exemple les ingénieurs
qui travaillent sur l'algorithme sont
aux États-Unis ou au Royaume-Uni mais il
y a aussi de très bons ingénieurs en
Chine et pourquoi ne pourrions-nous pas
travailler avec eux
quand on demande
dites-nous tout simplement puisque vous
travaillez avec designers chinois ils
travaillent dans des entreprises
chinoises donc nous vous demandons quels
sont les entreprises chinoises avec
lesquelles vous travaillez pas de
réponse
un mot sur le projet Clover
qui pour le moment est essentiellement
un projet dilatoire et qui est pour le
moment de toute façon insuffisant dans
la de la façon dont il est présenté
le projet Clover présente une grande un
grand inconvénient ce projet qui qui
consiste comme le projet Texas aux
États-Unis qui lui aussi est en
discussion depuis quatre ans mais qui
n'a pas du tout du tout avancé c'est
toujours c'est pas spécificat Tik Tok
c'est souvent le cas des plateformes
mais Tik Tok et le champion de cela
c'est les engagements des engagements
des engagements et puis ils ne sont
jamais tenus et puis on refait une
réunion parce que les autorités se
fâchent et puis ça continue comme ça
Texas c'est un projet Texas c'est-à-dire
le fait de confier à Oracle l'ensemble
des serveurs des données etc et est en
route aux États-Unis en discussion avec
le gouvernement américain de la part du
Tik Tok depuis 4 ans et il est toujours
au point mort on sait on sait quelque
chose de plus que sur Clover parce que
sur Clover on refuse de nous donner le
nom de la société avec laquelle des
discussions aujourd'hui avec laquelle on
discute pour faire la même chose qu'aura
que les États-Unis mais on ne veut pas
en donner le nom bon en tout cas aux
États-Unis c'est Oracle mais rien n'est
fait aujourd'hui aucun contrat aucune
aucune avancée technique en ce qui
concerne le projet Clover c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué en plus parce que moi
j'étais que ça il est aux États-Unis et
il est lié il est lié au droit américain
donc pas de problème mais si le projet
Clover doit se faire en Europe ça pose
le problème suivant c'est que
d'une part
c'est qu'il est soumis à trois il sera
s'il existe un jour il sera soumis à
trois juridictions à la fois la
juridiction européenne bien entendu mais
aussi la juridiction américaine et par
l'extraterritorialité américaine puisque
les logiciels de Cloud seront
probablement américains et que par
conséquent l'extraterritorialité des
droits américains s'appliquera à Tik Tok
et évidemment l'extraterritorialité
chinoise pour les raisons que que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure et notamment
parce que l'algorithme ne fonctionne
qu'en Chine
toujours sur le plan de
du mauvais élève en matière de de rgpd
un mauvais un mauvais élégant vos élèves
en fonction au regard de la protection
de la jeunesse comme vous le savez
Tic-Toc dit que cette application n'est
pas destinée aux enfants de moins de 13
ans et d'ailleurs la loi qui vient
d'être votée par l'Assemblée nationale
les Sénat sur la majorité numérique fera
en sorte que le contrôle parental
l'autorisation parentale devra être
donnée pour les mineurs au-dessous de 15
ans mais pour le moment en tout cas
Tic-Toc lui-même dit que son navigation
est interdite aux enfants de moins de 13
ans le contrôle d'âge
je sais pas comment le définir il est
d'une il est inexistant c'est à dire que
si vous avez 12 ans ou 8 ans vous pouvez
il suffit que vous marquiez 22 ans ou 25
ans et personne ne va vous demander
rien du tout par conséquent il n'y a
absolument pas le contrôle là Tik Tok
explique qu'ils ont des méthodes non pas
de reconnaissance faciale mais d'analyse
faciale parce que leur connaissance
faciale est interdit mais d'analyses
faciale d'analyses des messages etc bien
entendu c'est totalement inopérant
puisque
un seul chiffre aujourd'hui 45% des
11-12 ans sont inscrits sur TikTok je
sais pas si c'est en France ou à
l'international mais enfin en gros de
s'en servir au même 45% des 11-12 ans
sont inscrits sur des gueules
c'est-à-dire que ce contrôle d'âge
aujourd'hui n'existe pas ce qui posait
bien évidemment tous les problèmes non
seulement de désinformation mais
d'exposition à la pornographie un
certain nombre de sujets
qui qui sont extrêmement problématiques
le deuxième problème c'est un algorithme
j'en dis qu'un mot parce que vous le
savez aussi bien que moi un algorithme
particulièrement addictif il est
tellement addictif qu'aujourd'hui toutes
les plateformes sont en train de faire
la course à l'échalote pour rejoindre
Tik Tok dans les difficultés de
l'algorithme c'est d'ailleurs quelque
chose d'assez préoccupant de la part de
toutes les plateformes mais en tout cas
de la part de Tik Tok c'est
l'ablatoire qui a introduit cette
activité maximum
dont les
1h47 par jour en moyenne d'utilisation
de de la plateforme beaucoup plus
évidemment chez certains c'est une
moyenne ce qui veut bien dire ce qu'il
en est pour certains et notamment
certains enfants ou adolescents puisque
c'est une partie essentielle de
des utilisateurs de Tik Tok
les praticiens les spécialistes de
psychologie qu'ils soient théoriciens ou
praticiens
par le d'addiction d'autres disent c'est
pas exactement une addiction c'est pas
la même chose qu'une édition à l'alcool
au tabac ça me paraît un petit peu une
discussion sur le sexe des anges
certes d'autres parlent d'abrutissement
ce qui est certain au-delà des c'est
normal d'ailleurs au-delà des
discussions scientifiques certains
scientifiques
psychologues estiment que le danger
de tels utilisations et notamment de Tik
Tok est à relativiser parce que pour la
plupart du des utilisateurs il n'y a pas
de conséquences prouvées de la nocivité
de Tik Tok mais en même temps ils
ajoutent immédiatement de toute façon
nous ne pourrons le prouver que dans
plusieurs années
parce que c'est ces études là
nécessitent plusieurs années donc nous
n'a la preuve ni dans un sens ni dans un
autre ce qui n'empêche pas de
s'inquiéter parce que les autres ceux
qui sont des praticiens c'est-à-dire des
psychologues qui reçoivent les
adolescents qui
évidemment tous les adolescents ne sont
pas ne vont pas mal mais
quand vous avez des millions
d'utilisateurs il suffit qu'il y en ait
4 à 5 % c'est ce que nous disent c'est
praticien il suffit qu'il y en ait un
très faible pourcentage et ça vous fait
des centaines de milliers d'enfants qui
sont dans nos consultations et ceux-là
qui voit les enfants et les adolescents
en consultation sont je dirais je crois
que je peux employer le mot vous vous
trouvez des exemples dans le rapport
effrayés par un certain nombre d'effets
sur les adolescents l'enfermement dans
des bulles au moment où on construit son
identité psychique enfermement dans des
bulles de filtre perte des signes soit
logique mortifère
je parle pas des filtres du genre bol de
l'amour etc vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
effet prouver des écrans sur le sommeil
or il se trouve que Tik Tok et
massivement consulter le soir et la nuit
et fait des écrans prouvés sur le
développement intellectuel et la
motricité des très jeunes enfants parce
qu'il y a des très jeunes enfants hélas
qui sont sur Tik Tok
au Royaume-Uni 16% des trois quatre ans
regarde déjà TikTok
Tik Tok moderal les défis dangereux
l'Italie a du Séville renforçant la
suspension je dis bien la suspension de
tout accès à TikTok pour les âges non
prouvés à la suite de la mort d'une
fillette du au jeu de foulard à une
sorte de jeu du foulard
les seuls remèdes que propose TikTok à
cette effet addictif c'est le message à
60 minutes puis à 100 minutes
d'utilisation vous savez sans doute
qu'en Chine
l'application se ferme automatiquement
au bout de 40 minutes
les régimes totalitaires ont beaucoup de
défauts et tout mais sur ce plan là
c'est une décision certes autoritaire
mais dont on peut penser après tout
qu'elle est peut-être
que parfois
c'est les décisions prises ne sont pas
obligatoirement
déraisonnable quoi qu'il en soit en
France bien entendu le fait de mettre au
bout de 60 minutes attention vous avez
déjà passé 60 minutes
est évidemment peu crédible c'est comme
si vous mettez sur un paquet de
cigarettes attention la prochaine
cigarette peut vous faire du mal et
espérer que vous allez diminuer
drastiquement le nombre de fumeurs bien
entendu on est dans le dans le
déclammatoire et d'ailleurs Tik Tok ne
donne aucune le rendement demandé ne
donne aucune précision aucune
statistique sur l'efficacité de ce
dispositif est très probablement parce
que il serait bien en peine de
l'approuver enfin un mauvais élève dans
le monde de la culture nous avons reçu
un certain nombre de d'organismes
spécialisés la Société des Auteurs
Compositeurs la SACEM la Société des
Auteurs Compositeurs les
elle est claire et nette elle ne va pas
par 36 chemin elle parle de piraterie
intellectuelle elle dit que alors que
Tik Tok se prévaut avec booktok et le
Festival de Cannes et tout d'une grande
intervention de domaine de la culture
avec des chiffres
avec des chiffres qui sont
qui sont improuvables
quand il s'agit pratiquement de discuter
avec les acteurs culturels et notamment
les représentants des acteurs
culturelles la SACD c'est la Société des
Auteurs et Compositeurs dramatiques dont
le directeur ou Président je me rappelle
plus parle de piraterie intellectuelle
parce que en discussion en négociation
avec Tik Tok depuis plusieurs années et
que la discussion la négociation traîne
et qu'entre temps rien n'est payé
à la SACD et aux auteurs compositeurs
eux-mêmes de la même façon la SACEM qui
est un peu moins critique mais qui nous
a tout de même
expliquer la chose très souvent il y a
bien entendu un accord avec liqueur
alors que la SACD n'arrive pas à l'avoir
mais
l'opacité des données fournit par TikTok
rend impossible la juste rémunération
des ayants droits donc faute de mieux
ils se sont rabattus sur une solution
qu'il ne les satisfait pas mais qui est
un peu mieux que rien c'est à dire que
il
[Musique]
une somme fin forfaitaire à défaut de
pouvoir leur présenter les données
réelles qui et les pourcentages qui lui
permettraient de respecter la loi voilà
c'est assez c'est là encore encore un
oxymore
prenez la transparence et faire
l'opacité prenez l'intervention dans le
domaine culturel et en fait se moquer
des organismes représentant une bonne
partie des
activités culturelles pour se concentrer
sur des points très précis ceux qui font
du buzz ceux qui font de la publicité
ceux qui sont visibles comme booktok ou
comme le Festival de Cannes
et du CNC alors
la fin du rapport est consacrée à un
certain nombre de recommandations
la première de ces recommandations c'est
que la Commission a décidé de
d'accorder à Tik Tok un délai de six
mois pour se mettre en conformité
conformité avec beaucoup de choses et en
citer quelques-unes et notamment bien
entendu avec le DSA ça c'est pas nous
c'est la Commission européenne mais
pourquoi 6 mois qui pourrait paraître un
délai assez court parce que ce délai en
fait il court pas depuis aujourd'hui il
court depuis la création de TikTok
depuis en France qui court depuis 5 ans
et que depuis 5 ans rien n'a été réalisé
alors que certaines de ces de ces
exigences sont réalisables du jour au
lendemain je vous en cite quelques-unes
la première c'est d'apporter les
réponses attendues je vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure des liens avec la Chine si on
interdit aujourd'hui l'application dans
tous les pays européens sur les
téléphones des fonctionnaires si
certains pays ont tout simplement
interdétectable c'est pour des raisons
importantes de risque pour la sécurité
nationale la première chose que nous
avons demander par conséquent et qui est
vraiment d'une simplicité biblique c'est
d'apporter les réponses aux questions
que nous avons posées sur le capital et
sur les statues et sur les actionnaires
de la maison bidens ceci il suffit d'un
mail à la société binden skymans se mêle
nous l'attendons encore nous avons
demandé au ministre du numérique de
prendre contact prendre la tâche avec le
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
parce qu'il nous paraît bien entendu
anormal qu'une société opérant en France
ne soit ne donne pas et elle ne l'a pas
donné à aucun ministère pas jusqu'à nous
les coordonnées de d'une de sa
principale maison mère située dans un
paradis fiscal nous allons évidemment
appuyer cette demande j'espère que le
gouvernement français est capable mais
nous le verrons bien et ça
donnera des indications sur ce qui se
passe dans les sociétés des îles Caïmans
nous verrons bien si oui ou non on peut
avoir très facilement les données sur
les capitales et surtout sur les droits
de vote d'une société comme Biden situé
aux îles Caïmans
deuxième question la propriété les
détails de la propriété intellectuelle
de l'algorithme et la localisation et
les sociétés auxquelles appartiennent
les ingénieurs qui travaillent sur
l'algorithme et qui travaillent en
général sur l'ensemble de la technique
de Tik Tok en Chine et bien évidemment
que tikloque France ne peut pas ignorer
avec quelle société elle est en contact
avec quelques ingénieurs puisque par la
messagerie l'arc elle est en permanence
quotidiennement avec ces ingénieurs et
que si elle refuse de nous les donner ça
n'est pas un problème de manque de
données c'est un problème de
volonté d'obstruction donc cela ça peut
être fait du jour au lendemain
la nature des deux évidemment la nature
des données des utilisateurs transférés
en Chine ce qui est connu aujourd'hui
que par les fuites qui ont été
réalisées qui ont été connus par un
certain nombre d'organismes d'organismes
spécialisés américains d'organismes
privés un pas de la NSA ou de la CIA
mais d'origine privé américain tels que
BuzzFeed newsgard etc donc quelle est la
nature de ces données et quelles sont
les raisons du transfert et enfin un
certain nombre de précisions qui n'ont
pas été donnés à ce jour sur le projet
Clover de mettre fin à ses transferts de
données puisque tout ce que nous savons
du projet Texas et du projet Clover
aujourd'hui à aucun moment la société
n'a apporté la preuve que les portes
dérobées n'existaient pas et qu'il était
impossible de connaître les d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement
impossible c'est tout à fait possible de
connaître les données à partir de la
Chine
court également pour la prise de
certains des principales mesures
demandées par notre rapport
clarification des statues et
l'actionnaires de la maison mère bidens
séparation effective avec la Chine parce
que au-delà des données il faut
évidemment faire en sorte que il y a
pour des raisons de sécurité qui est une
séparation effectivement avec la Chine
qui n'existe que sur le papier
aujourd'hui mise en conformité avec les
prescriptions du DSA incluant la mise en
place d'une modération et d'une lutte
contre la désinformation enfin efficace
création d'interface de programmation
ouverte et transparente les API la
plupart des plateformes aujourd'hui sont
très réticentes et assez opaques
également en matière d'API mais les
donne et notamment pour les chercheurs
ou pour les régulateurs il y en a un
certain nombre ce qu'on nous dit c'est
Tik Tok avec
proclamant que eux aussi ont mis des
applications de Programming Interface
des des
interfaces de programmation
tous les chercheurs nous disent c'est
totalement évident il y a rien sur il y
a rien sur ces API beaucoup moins que
sur les autres applis qui déjà ne sont
pas des records mains dans la matière
présentation de garantie supplémentaire
pour le projet Clover et mis en place
bien entendu d'un contrôle effectif de
l'âge et de mesure concrète pour lutter
contre les adolescents c'est le contrôle
de l'âge il est d'ailleurs il est
d'ailleurs nécessaire il réclamé par le
DSA il est réclamé par le par les le
gouvernement français
il y a il reste peu de temps pour se
mettre le DSH vous le rappelle va être
effectivement à partir du 27 août donc
très très prochainement pour le moment
nous n'avons aucune idée des mesures de
contrôle effectif et notamment par le
biais d'un tiers de confiance c'est sans
doute la solution qui est la meilleure
et qui sera adaptée par la plupart des
plateformes pour le moment nous n'avons
aucune aucun engagement aucune de nation
il nous paraît extrêmement difficile que
ce soit réglé d'ici le 27 août donc si
moi supplémentaire
faut de cela nous estimons qu'il y a un
risque pour la sécurité nationale
notamment et pour le bien-être des
utilisateurs et notamment des enfants et
nous demanderons que des mesures
d'urgence soient prises éventuellement à
la pouvant aller jusqu'à une suspension
tant que les données facilement
communicables ne le sont pas parce que
sa témoignerait vraiment d'un refus et
d'une très mauvaise volonté par ailleurs
le rapport j'en ai bientôt terminé
décline plus en détail une série de
mesures
de l'instauration de notre système de
contrôle de l'âge dont je viens de
parler à la signature d'accord équitable
avec société de gestion collective des
droits d'auteurs en passant par la mise
en place d'une nouvelle législation pour
moraliser entre guillemets les
algorithmes de la prise en compte par la
plateforme Pharo ce cinéma de fausses
informations puisque cette rubrique
aujourd'hui n'est pas proposée sur la
plateforme Pharos
enfin à la suite des événements ayant
débuté la semaine dernière suite des
émeuts de la semaine dernière nous
estimons comme les auteurs de différents
rendements au projet de loi numérique
est en cours de discussion au Sénat et
comme le président
oui oui et comme le président de la
République a évoqué qu'il faut pouvoir
empêcher l'utilisation de certains
réseaux sociaux pour organiser des
infractions de désinfractions de masse
des émeutes des dégradations des
violences Tik Tok avec snapchat et
telegram a été en première ligne sur ce
sujet c'est évidemment un sujet délicat
car la liberté d'expression doit être
respectée et le
l'auteur d'un amendement le rapporteur
de la commission Patrick chaise qui
avait présenté un amendement demandant
pouvant aller jusqu'à la suspension
et à l'injonction
de retrait des contenus dans ce dans ce
cas là accepter à la demande du ministre
Jean-Noël Barrault de retirer son
amendement contre la promesse se mettre
en place très rapidement un groupe de
travail ministre par le député et
sénateurs pour arriver à trouver une
solution qui respecte à la fois la
liberté d'expression et la protection
des utilisateurs et la protection de
l'ordre public bien entendu puisque
c'est de cela c'est de cela qui est
parti le sujet nous pensons qu'il est
nous préconisons
la possibilité d'étudier un mécanisme
d'injonction administratif de retraite
contenu ou de blocage d'accès
parce que ce n'est pas un précédent cela
a été voté et cela a été accepté par le
Conseil constitutionnel pour la
pédopornographie ou pour le terrorisme
sous le contrôle du juge nous pensons
que les atteintes graves à leur public
tels qui tel qu'elles se sont déroulées
au cours des des
jours précédents doit pouvoir mais c'est
à discuter nous n'avons pas de
recommandation particulière c'est une
recommandation de travailler sur le
sujet mais doit pouvoir faire l'objet
d'une discussion et j'espère d'une
conclusion qui réunirai à la fois le
gouvernement et les deux chambres du
Parlement voilà
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres choses dans
ce rapport bien entendu mais je vous en
ai fait une rabbise synthèse trop trop
rapide d'ailleurs j'ai été trop long
mais bon c'était quand même le résultat
de 4 mois de travail qu'on tenait à vous
communiquer de façon la plus précise et
la plus détaillée possible maintenant je
vous propose de rentrer dans la
discussion sauf si auparavant certains
de mes collègues souhaitent ajouter
quelques mots
Catherine Morin de Sailly
oui parce que je dois partir l'Assemblée
nationale pour une commission
mixparitaire
j'aurais passé notre rapporteur parce
que sous et notre président parce que
sous leur conduite on a effectué un vrai
travail de fond et ça n'étonnera
personne il est en parfaite coïncidence
en matière de diagnostic et de
proposition avec les travaux qu'on
conduit de longue date notamment au sein
de la commission des affaires
européennes du Sénat notamment sur les
projets de règlement européen qui comme
la rappeler Claude maillothée vont
s'appliquer à partir de fin août veut
citer le RSN autrement appelé le DSA ça
lui André gatelin parce que André et moi
on a travaillé aussi sur beaucoup de
projets de règlement européen qui ont
trait à la régulation du du numérique et
est-ce que je veux souligner c'est que
le modèle économique de ces plateformes
de Tik Tok en particulier qui en plus
cette caractéristique des placée
finalement la tutelle du Parti
communiste chinois qui en fait
caractéristiques en soi c'est
l'addiction comme la comme la rappeler
Claude malurey mais c'est un modèle
économique en fait incontrôlable toxique
pervers et que on a pris un certain
nombre de mesures avec le DSA qui va
s'expliquer d'ailleurs hier nous avons
voté le texte à l'unanimité on a c'est
forcé de de l'enrichir et de l'améliorer
au maximum mais très fondamentalement
c'est notre diagnostic qu'on a partagé
aussi avec Claude et nous le disons à la
commission des affaires européennes
depuis deux ans avec ma collègue
Florence Patrice compta il y a à
travailler sur un statut de ces
plateformes
entre hébergeur éditeur il y a une vraie
responsabilité via l'algorithme qui
reste opaque et qui met en exergue telle
ou tel contenu fait monter en puissance
telle ou telle sujet donc on pense qu'il
y a une vraie responsabilité aujourd'hui
le dessin permet d'avancer dans plus de
relevés redevabilité mais pas
nécessairement vers autant de
responsabilités que nous souhaiterions
voir
accorder autre chose puisque c'est la
dernière mesure et préconisations du
rapport Claude c'est que on est
convaincu aussi que quand on met sur le
marché une application
quand on la revoit pour
l'améliorer il faut passer par une phase
selon nous
d'expérimentation surveillée ce qu'on
appellerait un safety ou à Lexy by
design comme un médicament qu'on met sur
le marché il doit être évalué avant
d'être complètement
autorisé à circuler et on estime que ça
devrait être le cas de ces plateformes
qui ont un potentiel
d'aductivité et qui peuvent mettre en
danger potentiellement aussi et on pense
à nos jeunes sur lequel on a beaucoup
travaillé ici ou cela c'est un étang au
regard des du pouvoir des plateformes et
des réseaux sociaux
voilà des des mesures qui sont un peu
fortes elles sont dans le circuit de la
la réflexion aujourd'hui
elles ne sont pas encore intégrées nous
l'avons mis dans des propositions de
résolution européenne avec notre
collègue aussi en penderie on a mis ça
dans des propositions européennes ça n'a
pas été pris encore en compte mais nous
voulons que la faveur de rapport tel que
celui-ci ça devienne Claude une évidence
une évidence voilà ce que je voulais
juste ajouter avant de de partir
mais il est plus urgent de reprendre
donc ma destin numérique et de faire en
sorte que ce petit monde là se trouve
correctement régulée
oui merci Claude peut-être en complément
de tout ce que tu as évoqué concernant
l'opacité de la maison Tik Tok il est un
élément qu'on a essayé d'investiguer
notamment lorsqu'on a questionné les
dirigeants français de Tik Tok c'est
celui du modèle d'affaires comment on
dit le business model personne ne
comprend comment cette société
fonctionne on a du mal on a très très
peu de données alors il existe des
données au niveau international ou au
niveau national sur le marché
publicitaire puisque là ça fait l'objet
de la part des acteurs du marché
publicitaire d'évaluation on a une
société qui emploie énormément de gens
au dire partielle on nous parle de 40000
modérateurs physiques dans le monde
c'est quand même beaucoup de gens quand
on regarde un certain nombre d'employés
aux États-Unis et qu'on regarde le prix
des salaires c'est extrêmement élevé
donc il y a énormément de dépenses sans
parler les dépenses technologiques la
recherche et la gestion en termes de
rentrée on est sur des niveaux euh de
publicitaire de 4 milliards de dollars
je crois au global en 2022 ce qui est
quand même extrêmement faible donc on a
l'impression d'une entreprise qui marche
à perte alors c'est vrai on dit souvent
dans le monde de l'Internet on perd
beaucoup d'argent au début pour en
gagner au delà je rappelle que le modèle
des réseaux sociaux aide d'une
rentabilité d'une arrivée à la
profitabilité extrêmement rapide
Facebook créé en 2004 gagne de l'argent
en 2009 là on a l'impression qu'il y a
une perte alors pourquoi faire et les
données et Tik Tok est assis sur une
mine d'or de données personnelles
elle ne les commercialise pas à
l'extérieur elle utilise elle l'utilise
pas sur une publicité
ultra ciblée tout ce qu'elle fait c'est
des écrans dans des programmes
extrêmement courts donc elle n'a pas
potentielle d'équilibre quid que mais
qu'est-ce que cela signifie c'est une
vraie interrogation est-ce que c'est pas
un instrument pour une puissance
étrangère que nous connaissons bien qui
se plaît à faire du machine learning de
l'apprentissage machine ou de
l'intelligence artificielle de capter
des données personnelles à ces usages
propres en tous les cas nous n'avons eu
suite aux questions qu'on a posé dans
les auditions aucune réponse claire
alors on nous dit ah bah oui la
publicité sur Tik Tok France ça
représente 62 millions d'euros par an et
on fait 103 millions de chiffre
d'affaires avec le live le live gifting
c'est à dire quand les utilisateurs
plutôt les gens qui fréquentent achètent
une monnaie virtuelle pour récompenser
les créateurs et les influenceurs c'est
quand même assez impressionnant 62% de
la ressource reviendrait du fait que des
enfants très jeunes achètent de la
roupie de sans son pour rétribuer avec
quel argent avec quel compte ça c'est un
souci pour leurs parents pour rétribuer
des utilisateurs et en quoi cela
d'ailleurs nourrit-il directement
l'entreprise Tic-Toc puisqu'elle est
supposée
reversée une partie de ses revenus à ses
utilisateurs bref un doute complet sur
la viabilité du modèle économique ce qui
nous laisse penser moi personnellement
tous les cas je la suis en tant que tel
que ce n'est pas une entreprise
économique c'est une entreprise
politique avec vocation de capter des
données personnelles pour un usage
beaucoup plus général dans le monde et
l'écosystème informatique global
avant qu'on passe aux questions je vais
juste ajouter un mot je remercie le
rapporteur et les commissaires du
travail qu'on a mené c'est un sujet qui
vers lequel moi j'ai été amené par une
comment dire une prévention généralisée
sur la question des plateformes et des
réseaux sociaux et je dois dire que le
travail qui a été mené à permis de
caractériser quand même une
particularité TikTok ce dont je n'étais
pas persuadé au départ et donc on a bien
vu plus on creusé plus on a vu que la
question des plateformes des réseaux
sociaux et des dangers globaux
il y a des dangers qui sont communs à
l'ensemble des plateformes et des
réseaux cette commission je pense a
permis de poursuivre le travail si je
peux dire de daigneusement et des
responsables et des acteurs publics et
privés d'ailleurs aussi et du grand
public sur sur ces sujets là mais qu'il
y a un effet de de loop et un effet
d'accélérateur quand vous êtes une
application à quasiment 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs dans le monde le
caractère globalisant de l'application
et le caractère exponentiel de du nombre
d'abonnés pose une question fondamentale
donc moi je vous remercie le travail qui
a été qui a été fait parce que ça permet
quand même de caractériser un doute une
menace une vigilance qui est
particulière sur cette application là
tout en permettant de remettre vraiment
sur le tapis les questions que évoqué
notamment ma collègue Morin de ci qui
est spécialiste du sujet ça nous a
permis aussi d'objectiver un certain
nombre de choses c'est à dire que
d'abord quand vous avez des questions
répétées en audition par écrit ou les
gens sont relancés on cherche à trouver
les réponses par nous-mêmes on ne les
trouve pas vous objectivez les choses
j'irai en creux par le fait que tant
qu'on vous oppose un flou c'est bien
qu'il y a un problème et qu'on peut
penser qu'il y a des choses à cacher la
question je reviens sur la question de
l'algorithme de la propriété de
l'algorithme sur laquelle monsieur le
rappeur rapporteur a beaucoup insisté
dans les auditions avec les responsables
entre guillemets parce qu'en fait on
sait pas vraiment à qui on a affaire
parce que Mazure semblait découvrir
qu'il n'y avait pas Tik Tok en Chine
données semblait découvrir certains
problèmes géopolitiques sur les wigours
ou franchement avec tout le respect que
que j'ai pour cette dame et toute la
compassion que j'ai eu pour elle pendant
le l'audition parce qu'à un moment
ça devait ça devait être long pour elle
surtout pour nous ça allait sur le fait
que on avait vraiment l'impression de
répondre qui avait été préparé ou mal
préparé avec une espèce de conseil en
communication oui à titre personnel je
suis sensible aux questions de
démocratie en tant que citoyenne mais en
tant que responsable je ne sais pas vous
dire si enfin au bout d'un moment des
gens qui ont la responsabilité de
contenu à cette échelle là ne peuvent
pas se cacher derrière leur petit doigt
donc ça a permis de déniiser ça a permis
d'objectiver d'objectiver aussi sur les
aspects scientifiques je voudrais
apporter une petite nuance d'un débat
qu'on a eu dans la dans la commission
pour l'adoption du rapport sur la
question de l'addiction c'est une c'est
un terme qui permet de faire comprendre
ce à quoi on est confronté que vous
constatez tous il suffit de faire un
voyage en train de se trouver assis à
côté de gens qui pendant deux heures
trois heures
défiler comme ça et au bout d'un moment
on a presque de la peine pour les gens
qu'on voit ne pouvant pas lever le nez
mais c'est bien qu'il y a un effet au
minimum d'abrutissement parce que nous
en dire un certain nombre de
scientifiques en audition et la question
de l'addiction malgré tout ce pose pas
de temps chez ceux qui font de l'étude
statistique et macro mais chez ceux qui
notamment les psychologues cliniciens
qui considèrent qu'au bout d'un moment
ils observent les mêmes phénomènes qu'on
peut avoir par rapport à l'alcool ou par
rapport à certains comportements par
exemple de déviance alimentaire mais ça
permet au moins de faire vivre ce débat
là et vivre le débat entre entre
scientifiques et c'était important qu'on
puisse auditionner autant de autant de
scientifiques et enfin le dernier point
moi je trouve que ça permet ce travail
qui a été fait il est de salut public si
je peux dire dans les circonstances en
ce moment que connaît le pays mais en
tout cas c'est de responsabiliser parce
qu'on a reposé la question de la
responsabilité des plateformes en
elle-même et des acteurs publics les
gens de Tik Tok à qui nous avons à faire
qui nous avons eu à faire ne peuvent pas
comme ça d'un revers de main considérer
que parce qu'il y a un partenariat avec
le Festival de Cannes ça exonère de se
demander pourquoi on tombe sur les
vidéos sur lesquelles on tombe alors on
a tous fait l'expérience y compris ceux
d'entre nous qui n'y étions pas sur
TikTok d'aller voir ce qu'il y avait sur
Tik Tok et enfin je veux dire moi quand
j'ai des gens qui qui s'extasient devant
des coffrets qui s'ouvrent parce qu'ils
font du placement de produit ou qu'on a
qu'on vous explique comment on fait
frire et refrir et repaner des quiches
dans de l'huile et vous tombez comme ça
sur des vidéos de de nourriture de
nourriture malsaine pendant des heures
et des heures c'est pas franchement
compensé par le fait qu'il y a un
partenariat avec le Festival de Cannes
et le fait que monsieur garrando nous a
expliqué que c'était les nouvelles
années folles la Nouvelle Vague etc je
suis pas sûr que je suis pas sûr je sais
pas s'il y a des gens ici des Cahiers du
cinéma mais enfin bon ils apprécieront
là ils apprécieront la comparaison donc
ça permet quand même de montrer qu'elle
est l'irresponsabilité ou la
responsabilité des acteurs publics on a
reparlé de la question des parents je
pense aussi que la question de
l'éducation sur le fond a permis la
Commission a permis de poser ce sujet
vous avez une une des intervenantes une
des psychologues cliniciennes qui est
cité dans le rapport qui explique que
200 points de vue c'est dès la maternité
qu'il faudrait avoir un temps d'échange
qui soit un peu institutionnalisés avec
les jeunes parents sur sur le les
méfaits qui pour le coup sont totalement
objectifs et scientifiquement et de
manière généralisée il y a un accord sur
la question des moins de 3 ans près
l'impact sur les plus de 3 ans il doit
être encore défini enfin tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il y a un problème
quand même donc là aussi il y a des
questions de responsabilisation et enfin
sur la question de la responsabilité des
plateformes ma collègue Morin de saillie
l'a dit à l'instant mais on ne va pas
pouvoir continuer à considérer qu'ils ne
font que regarder passer le contenu que
des abonnés mettent en ligne sans la
responsabilité de de la plateforme même
qui est un éditeur c'est à dire que je
fais nous sommes là devant des
journalistes professionnels ce matin le
filtre de la rédaction qui choisit ou
pas de mettre en ligne qui choisit la
façon de traiter qui en prend la
responsabilité ces plateformes ne
peuvent pas en être exonérées ça ne
tiendra pas sur le sur le moyen long
terme et donc il appartient au décideur
public maintenant de mettre un peu tout
cela au carré au-delà des règlements ou
des propositions de cadrage qui sont qui
sont faits par la par la Commission
européenne ou par les instances
européennes et c'est tant mieux mais la
question de la responsabilité du contenu
est énorme nous avons eu un consensus
dans la Commission et je crois y compris
dans les débats dans l'hémicycle ces
derniers jours sur le projet de loi
numérique sur le fait de considérer
qu'il y a une différence fondamentale
entre le fait de relater un fait de
montrer qu'à un endroit il y a des faits
de violence qui a un endroit il y a des
mouvements de foule qui a un endroit ça
brûle parce que c'est une une
information et puis que il n'appartient
pas à grand monde de décider qu'on
invisibilise des faits qui sont réels
dans la société qui doivent être
expliqués et montrer et le fait
d'expliquer que à tel endroit à telle
heure juste après le Zara on va aller se
faire le Adidas c'est que rendez-vous
dans telle condition ça ce n'est pas la
même chose quand on incite à la
commission d'acte violent donc ce sont
toutes ces finesses là qu'il faut
maintenant en responsabilité sur la
question de la responsabilisation
réussir à mettre en oeuvre et je moi je
suis content d'avoir fait partie de
cette commission et qu'on a eu je
remercie tout de malheureux d'avoir fait
la proposition de de ce sujet qu'on ait
pu apporter notre pierre à cette
entreprise de déniessement
d'objectivation et de responsabilisation
voilà
pour les personnes en ligne et pour le
compte-rendu si vous pouvez mettre le
micro et vous présenter merci Philippe
latiles factuel je voulais connaître le
calendrier la suite des propositions qui
va s'en emparer qui va aller traiter
comment ça va se passer la suite
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
interlocuteurs et plusieurs niveaux il y
a le niveau
législatif un certain nombre de
zébrobositions sont susceptibles d'avoir
une traduction législative c'est-à-dire
à l'initiative du Sénat ou à
l'initialiser nationale un certain
nombre de propositions de loi ont déjà
été faites ou de
sur par exemple sur la majorité
numérique
et celle là à partir du moment où elles
sont à l'initiative du Parlement je j'ai
pas beaucoup de doutes sur le fait que
vous savez que ces provisions de loi
sont à l'initiative des groupes
parlementaires qui ont des niches
parlementaires je ne fais pas beaucoup
de doutes sur le fait que des groupes
vont se saisir de ces propositions alors
je peux pas dire dans quel dans quel
délai mais à mon avis dès la rentrée
d'octobre prochain
il y aura sans doute des propositions de
loi de la part de différents groupes
soit de l'Assemblée nationale soit du
Sénat
deuxième partie un certain nombre c'est
propositions sont de destinées
au gouvernement à l'état à l'état
français
une partie d'ailleurs en relation avec
vraiment parce que si les Parlement peut
faire des propositions de loi le
gouvernement peut proposer des projets
de loi c'est le cas du projet loi sur le
numérique qui vient d'être voté au Sénat
et par conséquent un certain nombre de
ces propositions
seront présentées ont déjà été fait
l'objet de discussion lors des auditions
et en dehors des auditions à Jean-Noël
Barrault cette au gouvernement
maintenant de décider du calendrier
d'autant plus le calendrier est un peu
particulier puisqu'il nécessite d'être
harmoniser avec celui de la Commission
européenne et c'est le troisième étage
donc je me parlais laisser les tâches de
la Commission européenne qui va se
lancer et qui est en train de se lancer
dans un gigantesque travail puisque
après le rgpd nous avons maintenant le
DSA dans l'application doit se faire à
partir du 27 août c'est à européenne de
juger
je crois qu'elle a déjà donné des
qu'elle a déjà donné des échéances sur
et par conséquent toutes les
recommandations que l'on fait dans ce
rapport sur l'application du DSA
la Commission européenne a donné donc le
27 août pour la décision elle a déjà
désigné les plateformes qui doivent qui
sont susceptibles parce que les petites
les petits sites Internet ne sont pas
concernés bien entendu mais les
plateformes qui sont concernées il y en
a une dizaine pardon les très grandes
plateformes et
donc je ne l'ai pas en tête mais la
Commission européenne a déjà donné je
crois des deadlines des des dates
limites pour alors après à partir de ces
datimides bien entendu ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir des des procédures de
contrôle
qui certaines peuvent être rapides
d'autres peuvent l'être moins je ne sais
pas mais en gros voilà les les échéances
éventuelles
madame
groupe transpartisans dans le cadre
justement du projet de loi espace
numérique est-ce que l'un d'entre vous
va y participer ou d'autres membres de
la commission d'enquête
c'est comme pour la commission d'enquête
je pense que ceux qui vont y participer
sont ceux qui sont intéressés
et par conséquent il est fort probable
que dans chaque groupe
on va retrouver beaucoup de membres de
la commission d'enquête qui vont
demander à participer et comme ce groupe
de travail et
je dirais pas informel mais il y a pas
de règle de constitution
Jean-Noël barreau nous nous l'a promis
donc on va passer les vacances un peu à
réfléchir à cela à mon avis tous les
tous les tous les volontaires seront
seront tenus ça va pas se bousculer au
portillon mais de la même façon qu'on
avait 19 commissaires qui ont souhaité
faire partie de la commission d'enquête
je pense qu'on va retrouver une bonne
partie dans le groupe de travail pareil
à l'Assemblée
est-ce que vous avez
regardé comment ça se passe mais a
priori oui je serai sans doute candidat
je pense c'est sans doute notre fonction
de législateur qui qui
qui l'incit qu'il implique moi j'ai
tendance à séparer même si c'est souvent
sur des domaines voisins mais j'ai sans
doute tendance à séparer le moralement
du juridiquement nous nous sommes là il
y a des choses immorales qui
juridiquement de son pas sanctionnés il
y a des choses qui sont fonctionnées
même si elles ne sont pas immorales et
nous notre travail il est bien entendu
sur le plan juridique donc je voudrais
me cantonner au plan juridique oui des
inégalités bien entendu il y en a par
exemple
aujourd'hui la SACD nous a dit qu'elle
envisagée très sérieusement
des recours judiciaires sur le blocage
des négociations avec Tik Tok par
exemple des procédures de sanction sont
déjà lancées par la CNIL qui ont été
comme je leur transféré à la DPC sur les
les transferts de données par exemple à
CNIL a déjà condamné pour une amende par
une amende de 5 millions d'euros les
le non respect des cookies sur sur Tik
Tok et d'ailleurs d'autres plateformes
ont déjà été aussi condamnés donc des
inégalités il y en a il y en a toujours
il y en a partout il y en a même dans le
monde qui n'est pas le monde de
l'Internet mais oui bien sûr il y a des
égalités on en a recensé un certain
nombre il y a un certain nombre de
poursuites
il y a des inégalités par ailleurs qui
sont censés par farose sur toutes les
plateformes de la part des utilisateurs
et donc de la part du manque de de
surveillance des plateformes
bien entendu il y a des il y a des
inégalités elles existent déjà elles
vont continuer à exister
sur la suspension
le problème est
le DSA va introduire un changement de
pratique et confié à la Commission
européenne des responsabilités
importantes sur les plateformes pas sur
les plus petits qui seront toujours du
du ressort des des différentes des
différents régulateurs nationaux mais
[Musique]
ce DSA va confier des responsabilités
importantes à la Commission européenne
des possibilités d'injonction des
et notamment pouvant aller dans certains
cas jusqu'à la suspension
mais je pense que c'est cette pratique
va commencer à partir de du 27 août et
donc il va y avoir une série de
jurisprudences et on sait pas
aujourd'hui exactement je pense vu les
relations qu'on a eu à les auditions
qu'on a eu à la Commission européenne me
font penser
et notamment la mise en place du DSA sur
laquelle Thierry Breton est extrêmement
mobilisé me font penser que la
Commission européenne c'est jamais assez
c'est jamais suffisant c'est toujours
compliqué on est 27 mais me font penser
avec la Commission européenne comme les
États-Unis depuis quelques temps sont en
train de comprendre qu'il y a qu'il y a
un vrai j'ai l'habitude de citer
Barack Obama qui dans The atlantique il
y a quelques temps disait la phrase
suivante
les plateformes
numériques sont devenues les réseaux
sociaux pardon les réseaux sociaux sont
devenus un des problèmes un des dangers
majeurs pour nos démocraties et de la
même façon que au moment est bien placé
pour savoir pour savoir ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est un
utilisateur chevronné je pense que la
Commission européenne les Européens en
général sont en train tout à l'heure
michael va aller parler de déniaison je
crois que c'est toi qui a parlé de ça
moi je considère que nous avons par
rapport aux réseaux sociaux et alors là
parle pas que de Tik Tok je suis
intervenu à plusieurs repris sur les
réseaux sociaux
nous avons
d'une part une nécessité de
diagnaisement et d'autre part un début
de déniessement la guerre en Ukraine n'a
pas été d'ailleurs un des moindres une
des moindres conditions pour cela
j'ai recommandé je vous donne un exemple
j'ai recommandé en 2018 je crois c'était
au moment de la loi via 2018 ou 2018
c'était à l'époque à la commission de la
culture et donc on s'occupait des
problèmes et des réseaux sociaux
j'ai recommandé l'interdiction de RT et
de Spoutnik en France je me suis fait
non pas injurier mais agonir et
notamment par le ministre du numérique
de l'époque Cédric o en disant mais
enfin vous n'y pensez pas c'est un
problème de liberté d'expression et moi
je dis c'est pas du tout un problème de
liberté le directeur ad du FSB qui
produit lui-même directement à Moscou de
la stratégie de RT et de Spoutnik ce qui
était bien entendu une évidence tout le
monde savait que c'était cette société
ne nous ont jamais été des sociétés
commerciales d'ailleurs depuis la
directrice du RT est à Moscou où elle
fait sur les chaînes de télé une
propagande dingue pour aller tuer tous
les Ukrainiens mais c'est déjà ça dans
la tête à l'époque et rien ne s'est
passé le 27 février on s'est aperçu d'un
seul coup et alors là on n'a pas cherché
à savoir si c'était juridiquement fondé
s'il y avait un s'il fallait un jus ou
pas un juge on a décidé du jour au
lendemain quand suspendait RT et
Spoutnik enfin enfin et personne n'a
trouvé le moyen de le critiquer si
aujourd'hui nous sommes par rapport à
Tik Tok dans une série de problèmes
comme avec les autres plateformes sur
des sujets qu'on a évoqué mais l'un des
sujets c'est quand même le lien avec les
autorités chinoises et avec le Parti
communiste chinois qui qui dirige
l'ensemble de la manœuvre je pense que
on est dans une dans
une situation
où
s'il devait y avoir et les émeutes en
France
sont potentiellement un premier sujet il
y a un deuxième sujet sur lequel je vous
conseille de vous brancher c'est le
projet stop de Willow aux États-Unis
stop the Willow le Willow c'est un
projet de forage pétrolier en Alaska
qui a été
validé qui a été réduit par la Cour
suprême etc qui est depuis l'objet du
contestation il était c'était un grand
projet de forage et pour des raisons
écologiques etc il a été réduit il a
fait l'objet d'un consensus aujourd'hui
ce consensus est remis en question par
un certain nombre de réalisation
écologique sur lequel moi je n'ai rien à
dire si c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
justifié peut-être qu'il faut pas faire
de forage dans un Aska mais les
Américains et leurs congrès ont décidé
et leur parle le Congrès et le Sénat ont
décidé et le gouvernement ont décidé
qu'il fallait le faire pour un certain
nombre de raisons vous avez depuis
quelques mois une campagne qui se
déroule essentiellement sur Tik Tok je
sais aussi une campagne puisque les
adolescents sont particulièrement
concernés par cela mais à partir du
moment où vous avez ce genre de campagne
qui est en train de se développer sur
laquelle bayden est au joli très très
ennuyé parce qu'il est pris entre deux
feux entre ceux qui disent
il y a des problèmes de de livraison de
gaz et de pétrole et qui concerne
évidemment l'échelle mondiale nous avons
nos responsabilités il faut continuer
même si on est en transition énergétique
donc byden à côté qui qui a besoin de
fournir son pays un certain nombre de
pays en énergie et de l'autre côté une
campagne qui se développe comme sur
d'autres sujets
et notamment aux États-Unis et cette
campagne elle est aujourd'hui très très
largement sur sur Tik Tok à partir du
moment où vous avez une plateforme où
j'ai plus de
quelle est la différence entre Tik Tok
et les autres c'est la différence entre
le graphe social et le graphe d'intérêt
c'est ce qui est expliqué par les
chercheurs en informatique les autres
plateformes c'est elles fonctionnent sur
le fait bien sûr les réseaux d'amis les
recommandations de vos amis graves
sociales Tik Tok et fonctionne pas
là-dessus et je fonctionne en partie
là-dessus mais il fonctionne surtout sur
le graphe d'intérêt c'est à dire c'est
la boîte qui vous propose un certain
nombre de choses c'est vous qui décidez
en fonction de vos intérêts ça n'a plus
le même le même non pas business model
où sont économique mais le même modèle
de graves algorithmique à partir du
moment où vous avez une société qui sur
laquelle il suffit d'un pousseur
situé à Pékin éventuellement ou si tu
ailleurs s'il y a des pousseurs dans
chaque société nationale mais
la responsabilité éditoriale essentielle
et politique elle est à Pékin à partir
du moment où vous avez une société vous
avez plus besoin de faire les énormes
constructions que les Russes faisaient
sur Facebook sur etc etc avec les
fermatrol avec les milliers et les
milliers de comptes de faucontre avec
les milliers d'ingénieurs ou de petites
mains à Moscou qui qui
pirate les les Facebook
etc
là vous avez c'est beaucoup plus simple
vous avez juste besoin de gens qui
poussent tel ou tel ou tel ou tel
compartiment de de
influenceurs
c'est beaucoup plus direct beaucoup plus
beaucoup moins cher et ça peut se faire
d'une façon assez peu visible tant qu'on
n'a pas l'accès à ces désirs donc ce
genre de sujet qui peut se poser à mon
avis à tout moment parce que les chinois
ne suivent pas aujourd'hui d'intervenir
sur les plateformes occidentales et donc
ils sont engagés dans cette guerre
cognitive le jour où il décideront ils
le font d'ailleurs on peut le voir au
passage le aujourd'hui ce n'est pas Tik
Tok et susceptible par son nombre
d'utilisateurs et par la façon dont il
fonctionne de devenir une plateforme
utilisée dans le discours de propagande
et dans la guerre cognitive à partir de
la Chine mais il y en a une qui mais
elle ne l'est pas encore d'une façon
d'une façon
essentielle mais vous avez une
plateforme qui elle est d'une façon
essentielle c'est wechat qui s'adresse
aujourd'hui tous les Chinois de Chine et
hors de Chine et là je parle et c'est un
système international parce que les
community chinoises dans l'ensemble du
Sud-Est asiatique y compris d'ailleurs
en France aux États-Unis sont sont
toutes sur sur wechat qui lui est
l'exemple même réalisé d'une stratégie
d'influence chinoise d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'il faudra faire une
commission d'enquête sur wechat mais là
on est directement directement dans le
sujet et un sujet d'autant plus opaque
évidemment la plupart des gens dans les
pays dans les autres pays ne parlent pas
chinois et que ça reste à l'intérieur
des communautés chinoises mais qui ont
la directement visé par le pouvoir
chinois et avec une censure une
désinformation particulièrement donc du
jour au lendemain TikTok peut passer à
ce modèle et c'est là le danger
principal donc pour finir de répondre à
votre question si le jour où ce sujet
devient existant les mesures du type
allant jusqu'à la suspension moi ça ne
me paraît pas des atteintes à la liberté
d'explosion les attentes allaient y
avoir des expression c'est des actifs
les actions de renseignement de la part
de service secret
on a une question du
pour les échos
le rapport est évidemment très très
critique je voulais savoir si vous allez
trouver d'autres gens pour défendre Tik
Tok que les salariés Tik Tok
la difficulté c'est qu'on leur a il faut
je vous remercie pour votre question on
l'aura offert toutes les possibilités
de venir exposer les raisons pour
lesquelles il ne contre ni il ne
contrônait au à la règle existante et ni
il n'était en contradiction avec ce
qu'ils annoncent publiquement sur le
fait que grâce à booktok tout le monde
se remet à lire quoi bon je caricature
mais à peine c'est eux qui s'auto
caricatures donc on nous aurait proposé
des personnes à auditionner ou bien ils
auraient accepté que nous puissions
auditionner de surcroît en visio dans
les conditions qu'il souhaitaient et
nous avons tenu à reproposer par écrit
puisque monsieur Garandeau nous avait
dit que oui pourquoi pas il transmettrai
mais eux-mêmes je crois je parle sous le
contrôle des administrateurs n'avaient
pas eu de réponse au fait que nous
avions proposé plus haut à ce que leur
responsable soit auditionnés je veux
dire ils se sont mis dans la situation
de ne pas pouvoir être mieux comment
dire je vais pas dire défendu parce que
nous on n'est pas il y a pas de
procureur ici mais de pouvoir mieux
exposé les choses pour être tout à fait
honnête le petit bémol que je mettrai
c'est que certains
neuroscientifiques notamment nous ont
dit attention la question de la
socialisation des adolescents est un
moment important le monde est tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui il y a le numérique et
il y a un passage classique de la
nécessité de se trouver un groupe de
s'autonomiser un peu des parents de se
différencier qui passe aussi par cela
mais c'est comme le le poison et le et
le médicament tout est dans la dose oui
ma question était plus sur le les autres
interlocuteurs que vous avez pu avec
vous avez pu échanger donc hormis
quelques scientifiques
personne dans des associations de chez
les géopoliticiens on a défendu ne nous
ont dit vous allez trop loin ou
a priori non en même temps on a choisi
d'auditionner les gens qui s'intéressent
au sujet donc il est bien évident que
quand on demande à Monsieur Charron
spécialiste éminent non seulement de la
Chine et du discours du discours qui
sont publics à condition de savoir lire
le mandat mais de venir nous exposer un
peu ce qu'il pense de tout ça il nous
dit quelle est la stratégie affirmer de
la Chine il a d'ailleurs insisté sur le
fait qu'il était très étonné je crois
lui et une autre personne que nous avons
auditionnée dans la dans la foulée que
les déclarations tout à fait publiques
du régime chinois n'est pas fait l'objet
de plus de commentaires je crois à
partir de 2018 sur le fait qu'il est
tout à fait assumé sur l'aspect cognitif
comme sur le rapporteur à rodit qu'il y
avait comment dire au minimum de la part
des autorités chinoises la conscience
qu'il y avait des compétitions
cognitives qui se jouent à travers le
monde et c'est de là que on tire ou pas
les conclusions qu'on veut mais on ne
peut nous semble qu'on ne peut pas
écarter l'idée
que d'autres d'ailleurs chercheurs
avaient déjà évoqué d'une de se dire que
pendant que l'Occident abruti
de son propre gré Tik Tok et la version
chinoise de Tik Tok qui est visiblement
est beaucoup plus axé sur des contenus
culturels etc elle est verrouillée
Océane et le Figaro je crois
on est bien sûr que c'est LE FIGARO
clarifier les conditions précises qui
entraînerait une demande de suspension
et comment l'obtenir alors là je crois
avoir déjà répondu à cette question dans
mon introduction puisque j'ai énoncé à
la fin dans les recommandations les
conditions
réponse apportée par TikTok sur les
propriétés capitales et statues de la
maison mère propriété intellectuelle etc
des algorithmes et deuxièmement prendre
les principales mesures demandées par
les rapports que j'ai cités et qui sont
bien entendu détailler de toute façon
plus grande dans le rapport et puis la
deuxième partie qui fait l'objet du
groupe de travail qui va être mis en
place c'est le sujet des émeutes et de
l'incitation aux troubles alors
République sur lequel il y aura à
décider si les sanctions éventuelles
vont ou non jusqu'à la suspension mais
tout ça est détaillé toutes ces réponses
je crois y avoir largement répondu tout
à l'heure et sont détaillées encore plus
dans dans le rapport lui-même monsieur
s'était signalé après
madame bonjour Paul le roi de minimedia
il y a un point qui a été abordé un peu
en filigrane et qui me semble
intéressant c'est la partie publicitaire
est-ce que vous avez auditionné des
annonceurs des professionnels du
marketing qui vont qui vous aurez eux
aussi relaté une certaine opacité de Tik
Tok sur les indicateurs de mesure les
données utilisées ou d'autres points
alors
c'est en 6 6 a été évoqué en filigrane
c'est parce que ça n'était pas un des
objets principaux de la commission
d'enquête
et par ailleurs c'est un sujet
particulièrement complexe mais on
assiste sur ce sur ce sujet à peu près
au même phénomène que celui sur avec les
auteurs compositeurs ou la SACEM c'est à
dire l'absence la difficulté de la part
des annonceurs d'obtenir des retours et
notamment la difficulté à partir de
l'ensemble du système de pixels qui sont
je crois aujourd'hui qui sont répartis
sur des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de sites Tik Tok
utilise ce système de pixel sur des
dizaines de milliers de sites et
aujourd'hui moi je n'ai pas trouvé alors
il est pas évident non plus que les plus
que les publicitaires soient de le faire
parce que souvent ces chiffres sont
considérés comme confidentielles par
tout le monde par les plateforme comme
par les publicités eux-mêmes parce qu'on
veut pas divulguer les chiffres parce
que parfois ces chiffres sont pas fameux
donc il y a aussi il a une opacité sur
ce sujet de l'ensemble des données
publicitaires et notamment des pixels
mais on n'a pas creusé ce sujet
madame puis monsieur bonjour c'est un
héros pour politiqueo j'ai deux
questions la première est-ce que vous
avez pu parler avec Jean-Noël barreau de
vous propositions et la deuxième sur les
propositions de loi que vous anticipez à
la rentrée est-ce qu'elle concerneront
en tout cas de ce que vous en savez
anticiper seulement TikTok sachant que
certaines des propositions que vous
faites pourrait aussi s'appliquer à
d'autres plateformes je pense notamment
à la limitation du temps de 60 minutes
pour les mineurs à la recherche sur les
effets psychologiques
[Musique]
alors première question oui on a discuté
avec jardin on l'a discuté lors de
l'audition mais c'était un cadre
particulier donc avant tout interrogé
mais on en a discuté en dehors et
notamment lors de l'examen de cette loi
puisqu'on se voit très régulièrement
actuellement et
[Musique]
j'en ai le barreau est parfaitement
conscient du fait que le sujet était
volutif d'abord il y a des propositions
lois qui qui surgissent au moins 3 ou 4
propositions de loi depuis quelques mois
qui viennent soit de l'Assemblée soit du
Sénat deuxièmement lui-même a proposé ce
projet de loi sur le numérique et c'est
parfaitement qu'au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution il va y avoir
des discussions et notamment personne ne
pouvait prévoir il y a 8 jours que on
allait mettre en place à l'initialiser
du ministre lui-même un groupe de
travail sur la responsabilité des
plateformes dans les troubles à l'ordre
public donc oui cela va exister
deuxièmement
vous m'avez parlé de
sur les propositions loi est-ce que ça
concerne aura seulement
[Musique]
elle est faite pour tout le monde et par
conséquent et par ailleurs les
manquements
sont l'objet aussi de sur le fait aussi
de nombreux autres plateformes comme le
disait tout à l'heure Michael Valley sa
prévention au départ ne concernait pas
particulièrement une application mais
mais mais beaucoup et je suis assez
d'accord avec lui là dessus donc les
propositions de loi paraissent elles
concerneront tout le monde
juridique législatif il y a la mise en
oeuvre de ce qui est fait et ça c'est
une autre chose c'est à dire que nous
avons une réglementation dans ce domaine
assez complexe notamment pas toujours
les moyens de vérifier et surveillés
c'est pour ça qu'on a proposé d'élargir
les fonctions de pharoz pour des
signalements mais on découvrait
notamment que logiquement les sociétés
qui sont par exemple victimes d'une
cyberattaque entraînant un vol massif de
données doivent le signaler à Annecy à
ma connaissance tout ça n'est pas fait
on a posé la question aux gens de Tik
Tok ils étaient incapables de nous dire
ou surtout ils avaient pas la volonté de
nous dire s'ils avaient fait l'objet de
tentative d'attaque ou d'attaque qui
s'était soldés par des vols de données
je crois que les textes sont importants
la pour faire un anglicisme la capacité
à les implémenter à les mettre en oeuvre
et les mettre en oeuvre est une autre
chose et ça c'est toujours dans dans ce
détail là qu'il faut bien dire dans ce
domaine technologique notre pays comme
d'autres pêchent singulièrement donc la
bataille juridique c'est une chose mais
déjà mettons en œuvre ce qui existe et
ce n'est pas fait
bonjour Laurent Carpentier je travaille
pour le monde mais plutôt c'est la
sculptures
je trouve que en fait on est devant la
même impasse qu'on tombe toujours sur
Tik Tok c'est à dire que la différence
entre la question fondamentale de
l'économie sur lequel ils sont très
opaques et la question du de la
souveraineté nationale et je me
demandais si vous aviez interrogé
d'autres plateformes Netflix par exemple
qui est absolument la même opacité
économique alors sur la question de la
rémunération des auteurs d'une certaine
façon Tik Tok marche mieux avec les
puisque les entreprises font des deal
direct en fait donc il y a des deals qui
se passent pas par la CD je comprends
que Pascal regarde sois fâchée mais ça
passe par les Universal etc qui font
tous ou les éditeurs qui vont tous mais
la question fondamentale qu'à poser
monsieur sur la question de la publicité
et principale parce qu'aux États-Unis
quand la fertic-toc pourquoi interroger
Tic-Toc et pas une autre vous aviez dit
que ça ça vous avez niaiser par rapport
aux autres réseaux sociaux aux
États-Unis la fertic-toc commence à
cause des autres plateformes qui ne
comprennent pas que cette plateforme est
en train de les griller tous donc on est
dans une guerre commerciale au départ
qui devient aujourd'hui une guerre de
souveraineté de les griller après que
Tik Tok a acheté chez eux des écrans de
des écrans je parle comme un vieux
machin mais des comment dire de la
publicité voilà un coup de millions il
se pensait pas se faire doubler ils se
sont fait doubler en plus ils ont fourni
la balle quoi
on n'a pas interrogé les
ours on la seule chose que je peux vous
dire c'est que les la SACD la SACEM nous
disent sur ce les pratiques sont
complètement différentes les accords
avec les autres plateformes sont faits
depuis longtemps alors elles sont là
aussi depuis longtemps les autres
plateformes depuis plus longtemps mais
ils nous disent que ça prend toujours un
certain temps mais qu'aujourd'hui les
autres plateformes sont en règle sur la
communication des données d'utilisation
musicale sur le consulation et par
conséquent qu'ils n'ont pas de
contentieux avec les autres avec les
autres plateformes c'est juste sur ce
point que je peux vous répondre mais la
question la souveraineté nationale elle
est égale aussi avec toutes les autres
plateformes américaines si on n'a pas de
souveraineté nationale au niveau des
réseaux sociaux donc là on a juste faire
des Chinois donc en fait c'est une
commission d'enquête sur les Chinois
c'est pas une commission d'enquête
excusez-moi mais c'est un discours qu'on
a récurrent depuis le début dans le
monde politique et au début de cette
campagne nous dit on les Américains font
pareil c'est qu'on a essayé de démontrer
ça veut pas dire que ce que font les
réseaux sociaux américains sont bien et
qu'il y a pas qu'il y a pas un problème
de souveraineté là il y a une finalité
de du fonctionnement même du réseau
social qui au-delà de l'économie parce
que je veux dire les recettes
publicitaires de Tik Tok ou même
douilline en Chine ça marche pas mal
d'ailleurs de Yin mais les recettes
publicitaires sont ridicules comparés
aux autres réseaux sociaux
américains qui ont moins d'audience
moins de diffusion moi je suis je vous
cache pas fasciné depuis quelques jours
suite à la question des émeutes on ne
parle que de snapchat alors parce que
snapchat comme Tik Tok un système de
cartographie c'était une erreur du
président de la République dans ses
premières déclarations en disant il faut
pouvoir interdire ou supprimer les
messages mais le problème là dans les
ébots ce n'était pas les messages c'est
la cartographie automatique qui se fait
à partir de mots clés des endroits où il
y a des mouvements vous tapez emotes
ouest région parisienne vous avez la
carte des endroits où ça bouge en temps
réel c'est pas l'information qui a été
balancée par une personne extérieure ou
un contributeur c'est l'algorithme ça
existe aussi bien on ne parle que de
snapchat et entendez parler de Tik Tok
sur cette question je crois qu'ils font
assez bien leur relation publique je
pense qu'ils sont les premiers en mode
dépensent quand même beaucoup d'argent
mais ce côté de l'équivalent c'est à
dire ah mais les réseaux sociaux
américains font la même chose là on est
arrivé comme dans des choses où on ne
comprend même pas la logique économique
je sais au moins qu'on peut comprendre
la logique économique des réseaux
sociaux
américains là et l'absence de
transparence c'est-à-dire la volonté de
pas trouver qui est des négociations que
ça dure mais la volonté de ne pas
trouver des
nous voulons bien négocier mais il faut
que la base de la négociation soit
secrète comment une société représentant
des auteurs des compositeurs peut
décider au sud des gens qu'il représente
de dire nous négociants avec TikTok mais
nous n'avons pas le droit de dire ne
serait-ce exprimés le périmètre et le
volume ça c'est quand même des pratiques
excusez-moi qui sont dans le cas présent
totalement exclusif et quand le des
responsables de la SACD dit moi chez les
négociés c'est dur avec des grands
groupes américains mais que je sais pas
négocier avec le Parti communiste
chinois c'est c'est vrai que c'est des
formules un peu marquantes mais on voit
bien si vous avez suivi des 7 heures de
ou 6 heures de d'audition qu'on a fait
des dirigeants de TikTok enfin on avait
l'impression qu'on se foutait de nous
non réponse qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'avenir de la société ce qu'elle va
progresser en j'en sais rien à vous
quatre dirigeants vous arrivez à grand
renfort
dans une entreprise comme ça vous vous
s'occupait pas quel est l'équilibre
économique les projets de l'entreprise
quand je dis est-ce que vous allez
développer une plateforme bis comme
c'est fait aux États-Unis du type les
monnaie dit ah vous êtes au courant que
ça existe enfin franchement on a
l'impression que on est dans un monde où
on a eu 80% de non-réponses pour 20% de
réponse
approximatives je pense que aucune
société nous avons auditionné dans
d'autres cas des dirigeants de grands
groupes américains quand ils veulent pas
dire ils font des réponses juridiquement
organisées pour se préserver là on a
l'impression franchement d'être face à
un mur et et c'est ce qui nous rend
d'autant plus inquiet et en et en
logique de doute par rapport à cette
entreprise
alors moi
moi j'aurai deux éléments de réponse par
rapport à votre question qui est
qui revient en fait à dire pourquoi vous
avez choisi Tik Tok et est-ce que c'est
parce que il y a une spécificité
chinoise
ma première réponse c'est que c'est
indépendant de ça la deuxième c'est que
c'est dépendant ma première réponse
c'est que c'est indépendante de ça c'est
simplement qu'on a constaté avec
surprise que s'il y avait eu énormément
d'enquêtes journalistiques d'enquête de
certaines ONG d'enquête de certaines
entreprises sur Tik Tok en revanche au
niveau politique il y avait très très
peu les enquêtes n'avaient pas été
faites vous avez une enquête du Sénat
australien qui est assez d'ailleurs
intéressante qui est en cours et qui se
poursuit mais qui a déjà donné lieu à
des rapports partiels extrêmement
intéressants vous avez des enquêtes du
Congrès américain mais sur des points
particuliers à la suite de la décision
de Trump qui a entraîné un certain
nombre de de mais pas sur sur le système
global et vous avez
à ma connaissance pas d'autres rapports
parlementaires donc le premier pourquoi
pour une raison en principe assez simple
c'est parce que sur toutes les autres
plateformes qui existent depuis je crois
que c'était 2008 Facebook enfin c'est le
début des années 2004 on sait tout on a
tout il y a eu tout il y a eu le
Cambridge analythika il y a eu les
fuites de données il y a eu des milliers
de choses pardon Snowden voilà
parce que ça s'est produit au cours des
20 dernières années sur Tik Tok parce
que c'est plus récent enfin c'est quand
même 2012 mais ça a pris une dimension
internationale à partir de la fin des
années 2010
[Musique]
vous n'avez rien vous n'avez pas grand
chose et donc la première on s'est
demandé au début on a regardé et on
s'est dit pourquoi c'était une des
raisons de faire cette commission
d'enquête c'est qu'il y avait rien sur
Tik Tok alors qu'on en entendait parler
de plus en plus donc ça c'est
indépendamment de savoir si c'est
chinois ou pas chez moi la deuxième
partie de votre question c'est est-ce
que vous l'avez fait aussi parce que
c'était chinois et est-ce qu'il y a une
spécificité de ce point-là la réponse
c'est oui la réponse est oui bien
entendu que et on a dit tout au long et
dans vos questions aussi ça
transparaissait et c'est ce que vient de
dire André gatelin bien entendu que
l'ensemble des plateformes n'est n'est
pas sans reproche bien entendu que quand
je cite Obama pour Obama c'est toutes
les plateformes et que
et que jusqu'à présent d'ailleurs les
plateformes ont été peut-être plus
toxiques que tikloque qu'on a eu
l'occasion de l'être en raison de leur
passer avec l'élection de Trump avec le
brexit avec bolsonaro etc etc mais
aujourd'hui
la spécificité de Tik Tok et sa
justifier en dehors du fait que ça
n'avait pas encore été fait ça
justifiait cette commission c'est que
c'est pas n'importe quoi
d'être une société chinoise d'abord que
par rapport à tout ce qui se disait le
premier point c'était de savoir dans
quelle mesure c'était une société
contrôlée par l'État chinois et le Parti
communiste chinois parce que c'était pas
évident au départ et que l'opacité était
totale et je crois que ça valait le coup
déjà de le démontrer à partir du moment
où vous le démontrez bien entendu que
les les gafams ne sont pas exandre roche
bien entendu que la NSA est à la
recherche de tout ce qui de tous les
fuites de données qu'elle peut avoir et
tout sur les gafam Snowden ou la reprise
et nous le savons
mais c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
d'être dans un pays où les dirigeants ne
sont pas comme Jack ma ou comme
sanggaming privé de leurs actions du
jour au lendemain et disparaissent de la
circulation où vous avez l'obligation
d'une cellule du Parti communiste
[Musique]
il suffit d'appuyer sur un bouton apk il
suffit pas d'appuyer sur un bouton en
nez quand même dans une différence
fondamentale entre ce que sont les
démocraties et ce que sont les
dictatures
je peux ajouter juste un point parce que
votre question est très importante
je pense que c'est le cas de certains
nombre d'autres commissaires nous
n'avons enfin j'espère aucune naïveté
sur l'ensemble des régimes
et des hyperpuissances ou des pôles
principaux sur l'utilisation qui peut
être faite du numérique dans leur propre
intérêt national aux dépenses
je vous renvoie je fais une intervention
et que j'ai tenu à faire sur ce point
dans le cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire sur le fait que par exemple
titre personnel je pense que les
Etats-Unis d'Amérique sont un allié
militaire mais qu'en dehors de
l'alliance militaire il faut les
considérer comme un concurrent dont nous
devons nous méfier il y a des pratiques
d'otages économiques avec Alstom il y a
le fait d'écouter les dirigeants
allemands français par la NSA sans que
ça pose de problème derrière il y a le
fait de se faire lâcher sur la Libye au
dernier moment enfin je aucune naïveté
vis-à-vis des États-Unis vous savez dans
Z camp pour plais pardon la série j'ai
dit quoi ah pardon la Syrie
dans Z à un moment de manière un peu
ironique il y a je crois que c'est le
personnage de Charles Denner qui dit
c'est la faute des Américains mais
pourquoi parce que quand on sait pas
c'est la faute des Américains faut pas
non plus qu'aujourd'hui ça devienne la
même chose avec d'autres puissances ni
avec les Chinois ni avec d'autres
simplement la question numérique le
problème n'est pas le gouvernement
américain ou les autorités ou nos alliés
c'est le fait que ces plateformes c'est
grandes entreprises privées parce
qu'elles sont privées que c'est d'abord
et avant tout ça a été expliqué dans des
tas d'audition là pas du gain il faut
bien quelqu'un en face pour rétablir le
fait que la pâte du gain ne peut pas
tout et peut avoir des effets
collatéraux voire plus qui sont des
effets assez néfastes sur l'équilibre
des sociétés des démocraties et de la
bonne entente entre les peuples voilà là
il se trouve que Tik Tok pour les
raisons qui vous ont été exposés il y a
un lien particulier avec le régime
chinois moi je me fais aucune illusion
sur le fait que les beaucoup de de
startups devenus des entreprises
mondiales globalisé aux États-Unis ont
bénéficié de soutien public affirmés ça
prend d'autres biais mais c'est on peut
faire un parallèle de la part du
gouvernement fédéral américain et que
Elon Musk ne s'est pas fait tout seul
non plus et que si demain l'espace est
privatisé je sais que les États-Unis
d'Amérique ne sont peut-être pas
forcément contre vous voyez donc il y a
aucune naïveté de ce côté-là simplement
quand vous avez une application qui de
manière exponentielle gagne autant
d'abonnés que vous avez tous les gamins
j'ai donné cet exemple une ou deux fois
mais on fait souvent des visites de
scolaires au Sénat de nos départements
respectifs et quand vous avez des gamins
de collège et vous leur dites qui n'a
pas Tik Tok parce que et que en fait
même celui qui ne l'a pas ne n'ose pas
lever le doigt pour dire bah moi je suis
celui qui n'a pas Tik Tok vous vous
dites quand même qu'il y a un phénomène
global qui mérite d'être expertisé quand
même on aime bien savoir ce que ce que
ce que les gamins ou la population ce
qui a pas que les enfants il y a pas que
le problème vis-à-vis des mineurs sur la
question de l'abrutissement ont dans
leur poche voilà donc vraiment là dessus
c'est important de dire que on a étudié
le sujet jusqu'au bout il se trouve que
la relation elle est avec le
gouvernement chinois mais je pense que
nous n'aurions eu aucune pudeur par
ailleurs si la question s'était posée
sur d'autres d'autres sujets et je peux
être taxé ni d'européisme Béa ni de ni
d'américanisme primaire dont le
président a eu l'occasion de dire que
c'était le socialisme des imbéciles
d'après le général de Gaulle mais
l'anti-américanisme mais je crois que le
la citation est apocryphes
et puis on va être essayer de conclure
sans qu'il y ait de frustration sur des
questions d'en poser monsieur d'accord
j'ai le bonheur de l'AFP j'avais juste
donc deux questions une sur la les
questions de cybersécurité quand même
est-ce que vous avez pu avancer un peu
par rapport à ce qu'on savait sur la
dangerosité réelle de d'avoir cette
application installée sur son téléphone
par rapport à d'autres applications
qu'elles soient chinoises ou pas est-ce
que vraiment celle-ci vous avez pu
relever des particularités particulières
et puis la deuxième question c'est quand
vous vous décrivez le contenu
abrutissant ou autre contre sur Tik Tok
est-ce que c'est pas vous qui tombez un
peu dans la caricature dans le sens où
il y a tout un écosystème ou même de
créateurs qui s'est développé cette
application il y a également tout le
personnel y compris politique des
ministres le président qui communiquent
sur cette application donc finalement
vous parlez aussi de déniellement qui a
fait preuve de naïveté et est-ce que
vous recommandez
au-delà des eaux IV à vos à vos
collègues aux personnes politiques de
cesser utiliser l'application puisque il
donnerait des armes à l'ennemi dans une
guerre cognitive voilà je voudrais un
peu clarification là-dessus merci
je veux bien dire juste un mot sur la
cybersécurité sur pour préciser mes
propos sur le déniement et
l'abrutissement moi je dis je dis
abrutissement pour être complémentaire
par rapport à la question de l'addiction
c'est en fait pour être complet par
rapport à ce que nous ont dit des
scientifiques que nous avons auditionné
certains parlent d'addiction pour des
raisons que vous verrez dans le rapport
et qui peuvent parfaitement justifier
d'autres préfèrent le terme
d'abrutissement pour ne pas mélanger ce
que sont des addictions médicales entre
guillemets réels donc c'est pour ça
qu'on emploie les deux termes tomber
dans la caricature écouter je ne sais
pas ça à la rigueur le président a très
bien fait de dire tout à l'heure qu'il
faut distinguer les aspects purement
juridiques et législatives des aspects
moraux bien qu'on fasse jamais du droit
sans un peu de de morale et baigné dans
un bain culturel particulier qui est le
nôtre c'est normal mais simplement je me
garderai de dire que c'est un truc pour
les abrutis pour la ligne c'est
absolument pas le propos moi je sais ce
que j'en pense
personnellement et je ne suis pas épaté
par les comment dire les arguments
donnés par Monsieur Garandeau quand on
les met dans la balance c'est d'ailleurs
bien expliqué dans le dans les propos de
Monsieur le Rapporteur dans dans le
rapport quand on met en balance le
partenariat avec le Festival de Cannes
et d'un côté ce qu'on voit la réalité de
ce que les gens consultent et des vidéos
que je dis ça de manière objective et
qui ont le plus de millions de vues je
veux dire quand le Figaro la semaine
dernière alors j'ai juste vu que je suis
abonné que je lis le Figaro je le dis
par avance mais quand des grands
journaux quand on a des des
quand on a des des articles sur des
questions qui se passent sur Tik Tok je
suis de la semaine dernière c'est sur la
question d'une influenceuse qui est
déçue parce que la tarte qu'elle a
acheté dans une je ne sais plus quel
pâtisserie lui a été vendu cassé et que
ça fait un tam-tam pas possible pendant
plusieurs jours avec des millions de
vues sur le sur l'Internet chacun pense
ce qu'il veut de ce que devrait être la
société pour qu'on progresse si vous
voulez sur des sujets intéressants mais
après c'est une opinion qui est qui est
purement personnelle maintenant sur la
naïveté je pense qu'on est quelques-uns
mais là je parle comme mon nom à penser
que oui il y a eu de manière générale
une forme de naïveté sur la question des
des plateformes et qui un certain nombre
de responsables et de décideurs et pas
seulement politique ont été long à
comprendre que quand c'est gratuit voilà
vous connaissez la vous connaissez la
formule mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de la manière dont les choses ont
été objectifées par la Commission dans
la conduite des débats et dans le choix
des personnes auditionnées et dans le
rapport c'est cela qu'il faut qu'il faut
regarder et le rapporteur a souvent cité
la question du pharmacon c'est aussi la
question de la dose je veux dire moi
aussi je trouve mignon quand un petit
chat tombe ou fait une tête particulière
et tout ça est très très choupiné mais
si vous voulez ça va 30 secondes quoi
peut-être sur la cybersécurité moi je
suis toute façon toujours inquiet quand
il y a des milliards de données
personnelles qui sont possédés par un
seul groupe est-il un en mesure déjà de
les sécuriser au-delà de l'usage qui
n'ont fait lui-même et la question de
ces conservations de la conservation de
ces données la difficulté qu'on a c'est
qu'on est dans un média on est dans le
premier média teenager au monde en
termes de volume nous avons des jeunes
entre allez on va dire beaucoup 13 voire
12 et 17 ans qui sont dans une période
de transgression et dans les challenges
qui sont menés on les incite à la
transgression donc vous retrouverez vous
êtes peut-être trop jeune pour avoir un
fils mais qui montre ses fesses ou qui
va faire semblant à les savoirs de
prendre un rail de cocaïne etc cette
image là il a 15 ans dans 5 ans il entre
à Sciences Po d'accord très bien il
s'est bien rattrapé et dans 5 ans après
ou
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si c'est pour l'assurance ou si c'est
par générosité humaine là en la matière
c'est pour ça que nous nous attachons
nous voulons très clairement que les
vols donnés les attaques cyber soit
déclarés en particulier on le fait pour
les entreprises détails obligation pour
les opérateurs
d'importance vitale logiquement pour les
grandes plateformes quand vous avez des
milliards et des milliards de données
sur vous sur vos enfants et que
en cas de vol ou de portes ouvertes il
n'y a pas d'obligations de déclaration
vous imaginez ce vers quoi ça nous
dirige en termes de société c'est bien
ça je crois le problème de notamment de
la cybersécurité je pense que pour
protéger leur algorithme et leur façon
de travailler et leur système
d'intelligence artificielle Tik Tok ou
les gens de Biden sont très forts je
pense pour protéger leur donner et les
garder dans un cadre et notamment
comment leur demande dans un cadre
territorialisé précisément pour qu'ils
passent ces transfert données toutes les
incertitudes existent c'est ça le
problème
je voudrais juste pas être long parce
que
mes collègues ont déjà répondu juste
apporté une précision parce que vous
avez notamment parlé en matière de
cybersécurité pas tellement des
problèmes de transfert de données mais
de recueil de données sur les appareils
donc là je vous renvoie au rapport parce
qu'il y a plusieurs pages dessus qui
sont très très clair le nombre de
permissions demandées sur les appareils
qu'ils soient sur Google Store ou qu'il
soit sur
l'Apple Store sont comme une mesure et
vous verrez les détails dans le rapport
par les sociétés qui l'ont qui l'ont
examiné avec les permissions de demander
par les autres applications
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions ni en
ligne non c'est bon monsieur
en ligne on a pas d'autres questions
écoutez je vous remercie
pour cette conférence de presse durant
laquelle pendant deux heures nous avons
pu
ne pas être sur les réseaux